wealth breakthroughs is an exclusive
video series where millionaires break
their silence on their usually hidden
secrets on how to stack up great wealth
it's like EES dropping on the private
conversations Rich folks have with each
other behind closed doors but I
partnered with the series Creator Jeff
Hayes to bring that VIP pass to you
right here today in this episode you'll
learn John D rockefeller's secret to
massive wealth the four Investments That
guarantee returns how to break the
chains of a 9-to-5 life and how to get
rich regardless of your age or
circumstances get ready to be inspired
because today we're all about turning
your dreams into Dollars
enjoy hi there thanks for tuning in I'm
Patrick gentempo and welcome to episode
four of wealth breakthroughs I don't
even know where to begin to introduce
James Al toucher he has one of the most
famous podcasts on Earth he's a
bestselling author he's made Fortunes in
the hedge fund world and also become one
of the leading Tech commentators and
crypto experts around he's also
remarkably humble honest and has a
self-deprecating sense of humor like few
other people I've ever met today he's
going to show you the lessons he learned
from losing millions of dollars and how
those lessons helped him make many
millions
more he also used one simple easy toog
grasp strategy he says took him from
near homelessness to phenomenal success
that changed his life get ready for the
most unique wealth breakthrough you've
seen so far here's James all
[Music]
toucher James thanks so much for doing
this really excited to have this
conversation you know thanks for having
me on this show I'm really uh pleased
and honored to that you thought of me
for this well with what's interesting is
trying to consider okay where are we
going to go here there's a lot of places
we could go with you that you could
speak to uh but let's just first start
with your background what led you to
doing what you're doing today uh you
know I'm doing a lot of things today so
I'm a big believer that you know
everyone always tells you be focused
stay in your lane I don't think I think
that's horrible advice and I don't I
think that works in the self-help world
but doesn't work in the real world where
I think there's a big difference I think
it's important to explore and experiment
not only ways to approach a career but
ways to approach a life so what am I
doing today I love to write I've been
writing every day for 30 years I do a
podcast I uh have been an entrepreneur
I've been an investor I've I've run I've
been an advisor and board member of many
companies ranging from zero dollars in
revenues to billion dollars in revenues
the billion dollar in revenues went to
zero the zero went to a billion so it's
funny how that works out but uh I kind
of came through this in a very different
way than usual I wasn't very interested
in being an entrepreneur
entrepreneurship is brutal and hard and
often painful at least for me I wasn't a
natural I was I was natural at being
creative and helping other people I
wasn't natural at managing people or
figuring out the accounting or Prof
margins or things like that I had no I
had no business background I was a a
computer scientist uh and then I got
kicked out of graduate school because I
wanted to write a novel so every day I
was writing fiction and finally they
said they wrote me a letter and they
said when you're mature enough we really
like you but we can't let you sit here
on a fellowship when please leave
tomorrow and when you're mature enough
you can come back that was was in 1991
they do occasionally ask me if I want to
come back it's about almost 28 years
later and I haven't come back yet what
were you in grad school for computer
science computer science yeah I was very
interested in artificial intelligence
computer science uh I my one of my
projects I was working on I went to
graduate school where the computer uh
that eventually became deep blue was the
computer that beat the world chess
champion Gary Kasparov many many years
later seven years later and I was
working on that IBM actually had offered
me a job to continue with the team to
work on it so IBM essentially bought the
team of which I was partially on and
asked us all to go to IBM I stay I said
no I was one person who said no but I
enjoyed working on it and but then I I
switched interests again I I believe in
exploring what you know you have this
inner compass and at different points
the compass changes direction and you
should follow it like I wasn't going to
spend the next 5 years in graduate
school if what I was really interested
in was doing something completely
useless that would never make me a dime
of money and that's all I did for years
and years afterwards so finally I got a
job at HBO you don't mind me going into
all this background dude no but I'm a
little curious and Confused computer
science novelist the normally those are
two very different dispositions or
different types of minds and people so
so how how is it that these two things
were coexisting in your life did you
feel sort of schizoid or were you just
losing interest in computer science uh I
wouldn't say I was losing interest in
computer science but I would say often
you have to kind of look around at your
life and look at the people who are
succeeding in what you want to do and
you have to say to yourself do I want to
be like them when I grow up and I still
do this I'm 51 I still look around and
say do I want to be like this person
when I grow up and I looked at my
professors I wasn't that excited by the
work they were doing I still loved
computers and so on but then I I I just
loved reading and writing you know the
thing they teach you in first grade I
really wanted to do it for a living and
I would just not go to school anymore I
stopped going to classes and I would
read for three or four hours every
morning and then I'd probably write for
a good 6 to 8 hours in the afternoon and
evening I didn't I did an experiment for
a while just because I wanted to kind of
balance social life but also have good
quality very quiet writing time and I
still wanted to sleep eight hours a day
so here's what I did I slept from 4: to
8: in the afternoon and 4: to 8: in the
morning so from 8: in the evening till
midnight I would go to dinner and hang
out with my friends and then from
Midnight to 4 in the morning I would be
able to write then 4:00 to 8: in the
morning I would sleep and then I would
read until uh you know whenever and then
uh uh and then I'd sleep again and it
all the cycle would all start did it
work yeah it was great and then I was
always experimenting with sleeping
another time I decided I'm going to have
a 25h hour day so I'll get an EXT I'll
miss a day every 25 days but I'll have
an extra hour every day to work so I
would just basically stay awake I'd
sleep eight8 hours a day but stay awake
another hour So eventually I'm sleeping
from you know first I'm sleeping from
you know 10 p.m. to 6:00 a.m. but then
gradually a few weeks later I'm sleeping
from noon to 8:00 p.m. and I just push
it back an hour each day so that was
another experiment how'd that one work
out not as well not as well I would get
tired but I did that for many years and
I kind of went through that phase where
I thought I was great when actually I
was awful but fortunately I was hiding
in plain sight I was just writing in and
and not really showing it to anybody I
and I wrote during that period I wrote
four novels and and dozens and dozens of
short stories all of them awful like the
worst things possible but during that
time of course I got thrown out of
graduate school I I had failed all my
classes I got thrown out of graduate
school still good enough that IBM
offered me a job despite being thrown
out uh to work on the world
this Amazing Project which became the
first chess computer to beat uh the uh
the world chess champion it kind of was
the dream of AI since the 1950s are you
a chess player I'm a chess master Yes W
and I say that not in a bragging way
there's people much stronger than me uh
including Gary Kasparov the world chess
champion who's lives around the corner
for me now but 20 years ago I had helped
build the computer that that beat him
but uh instead of taking this amazing
job that would have been also a lifelong
dream I decided you know I'm going to
get thrown out of graduate school and
write horrible novels instead and uh
they again they asked they said I could
come back whenever I wanted but I never
did in fact the dean that threw me out
of graduate school is now one of my
closest friends he's he's my only friend
left from graduate school the actual guy
who threw me out but a few years later I
decided you know what I can't do this
forever I applied for a job at HBO
and I had no experience in the
entertainment industry I only knew I had
only worked as a computer programmer to
make money so I I had the low after
going to undergrad for computer science
and grad school for computer science I
had the lowliest job I was a junior
analyst programmer was my title at HBO
and just to mention I do really believe
in this idea follow your compus so at
the same time I had two job offers one
was at JP Morgan and the salary was 8
,000 a year the other was at HBO in New
York both were in New York City HBO for
40,000 a year I took the HBO job why I
hate Banks I love television not going
to take simp yeah it's that simple I
never even thought twice about it I
never even considered but here here's
what happened at HBO for a few days I
basically crash everything I touch and
finally my boss walks into my cubicle so
all the other eight attached cubicles
you know they're all listening and he
says you're not doing well here it's not
working out for you but we don't want
you to fail of course I'm horrified I'm
the new guy everybody's listening in the
cubicles around me is so embarrassing he
had no clue how embarrassing it was and
he said we're going to have to send you
to remedial programming classes I was an
undergraduate major at one of the best
computer science departments and then I
went to gra again I had put in 10,000
hours programming already and but it
just just goes to show you education
gets you you know being in a classroom
gets you good at being in a classroom
but does not get you good at the real
world and so I was great at programming
for the classroom but I had no computer
skills so I go to these remedial classes
finally I get back to HBO and really
begin my first real serious job I didn't
want to start a business at that time
but nor did I want to do what my bosses
told me to do so I was very interested
in the internet the internet was this
new thing this was
1994 and I said to my you know HBO was
trying to do interactive TV at the time
and through cable lines and I said to my
boss why don't you use there's this
brand new thing the web on top of the
internet here's this browser or Netscape
it's slow but you could potentially
stream video why don't we try that and
he was like James James James the
internet is for academics why don't you
let the cable guys do what they're good
at you just do what they tell you to do
and so there was one weekend where no
one was around and I completely wired up
HBO for the web I put I installed
Netscape on every single computer and I
I took every database at HBO and figured
out how to put it on you know an
internet H they didn't even have the
word internet then an internet so I had
everything from the employee database to
the mo HBO has a movie database that's
kind of like IMDb where you know you
click on uh a movie star you click on
Alec Baldwin and you see all the movies
he's been in you click on a movie you
see all the stars of it and so on you
could click on their deals potentially
and they even had their cafeteria menu
so I put everything online and when
everybody got back Monday I showed
everybody and they were terrified
because I had basically reimplemented in
a weekend all of the projects they were
hand building or you know without a web
browser and so but but but actually got
very popular and then all of Time Warner
wanted to do it so I was advising almost
all the different divisions of Time
Warner I remember at one point Comedy
Central which Time Warner HBO own half
of they called me over and they said
look can you we'll pay you as a
consultant even though you're an
employee at HBO we'll pay you as a
consultant can you give us uh an
internet and I said to them I don't want
to get paid I only want to do it if you
give me the 3:00 a.m. time slot you only
put infomercials there right now just
give me the 3 a.m. time slot and they're
like what are you this woman who's the
head of IT what are you going to do with
it and I said I just want to walk around
at 3:00 in the morning and interview
people uh for the 3 a.m. time subop on
com Comedy Central and then I'll build
your internet for you so to her credit
she took it all the way up to the CEO of
Comedy Central Doug Herzog who later
became the CEO of MTV he said no
correctly and I didn't do an internet
for them but I realized oh okay well
every company in New York City needs a
website and they don't even know it yet
and there's maybe five people in New
York City who know how to build a
website so at the same time my
brother-in-law contacts me his business
is falling apart what did he do he made
CD ROMs for a living which don't exist
anymore there's a reason his business
fell apart or was falling apart and I
said why don't you try this thing I'll
show you this thing called the web so he
was a good designer he's designing for
the web and I showed him some of the
software stuff but he still couldn't he
he didn't speak English he was French
and French people never learn English I
think he he was here for 20 years
already but he still didn't speak
English and he certainly didn't write
English so he he's like can you help me
write proposals okay I said okay so
suddenly now I'm kind I'm an full-time
employee at HBO but I'm writing I said I
don't want to be part of your business
I'm not interested in that I want to
eventually make a TV show for HBO but
then HBO said to me look you made this
internet why don't you be in charge of
hbo.com we need a website so I said okay
but I said let's Outsource it to a good
company that makes it so I did
competitive bidding four or five
companies the only four or five
companies in the city uh bid to do the
website uh I picked one company that was
the cheapest and the best so I called
him up to inform him my brother-in-law
where I had written the proposal to me
you got the deal and then I eventually
left HBO and joined the company
full-time and actually you know we were
Partners in it and I was the in charge
of it and we built up a very big company
building websites uh I built we built
americanexpress.com time warner.com con
edison.com
all the all the movie studios and maybe
you could tell by the way I look uh we
built every gangster rap record label
websites so loud records Bad Boy Records
Death Row Records introscope Jive we
built all the websites for all their uh
labels and we built up a nice company we
had this niche in the entertainment
industry and So eventually like all of
these companies we got Acquired and
stock we got acquired by a public
company stock went way up we I sold
every last time I said this is going to
be a bubble uh of stocks it's eventually
the internet's here to stay the
internet's not in a bubble but Wall
Street seems to be going crazy all these
money people are going crazy so I sold
everything what year was that about this
is 1999 I sold in 1998 started in 1995
sold it in 1998 cashed out in 1999
really at a good time and then I made
after making 10 good decisions in a row
I said you know what this internet thing
is here to stay I'm just going to invest
it all back into internet companies oh
no and but it'll be Diversified it'll be
a lot of internet companies and which
was not diversification I didn't know
that then and within eight months I lost
$15 million and I was broke I was dead
broke I I had I remember one time I went
to my ATM machine and I accidentally saw
how much was left in the account I was
such I was so depressed and so horrified
by my actions that I had refused to look
at my bank account whenever I logged on
but this one ATM like said oh $143 left
and that same account had had over $ 15
million eight months earlier you went
from 15 million to 143 in8 months yeah I
just said that yeah I know I didn't
really need to be reminded I don't need
to be reminded it that much well I want
to bring you back there because what
were you thinking at that point I was
suicidal I was I was really depressed I
thought to myself I'm not a businessman
I'm not an entrepreneur I somehow won a
lottery ticket in this in the biggest
crazy boom ever and I'm never going to
have this opportunity again I had
generations of savings for my children
grandchildren great grandchildren I was
going to I I had bought my parents a
house so you're literally depressed and
suicidal um you had all these maybe
self- Impressions about you know I'm I'm
not a good businessman I'm not a good
entrepreneur but I already knew in
advance I was I really did not enjoy
entrepreneurship or being a businessman
but I was very good I was I had two
things going for me I was passionate
about what I was selling so I really
believe that every company only was
going to have a website but they needed
a website so I really can go into any
business and explain to them why and I
had the skills to to prove it like I
could make them a website faster and
cheaper than any other company in town
there was literally there were four
companies and mine in town but I didn't
like managing people I didn't really
understand that so I tended we had a lot
of employees but I tended to do
everything myself uh I didn't really
know how to un how when people were
bickering or fighting or if two
employees were having sex with each
other I didn't really know like how to
manage these things it was just my
brother-in-law and me like kind of
locked in our room doing all the most of
the work and I would do 100% of the
sales and so because I was so passionate
about this and what the future was and
my you know how I could help them and
brainstorming ideas for what American
Express could do what HBO could do so
for instance for HBO and again I'd work
there but they became a the biggest
client of my business for HBO I said to
them you do such a great job making
original TV shows you're the first cable
company to really create these amazing
original TV shows the web is this brand
new entertainment medium no one knew
what the web was really going to turn
into be and so I said the web is this
brand new entertainment medium why don't
we do original web shows so they said
sure and so this was probably the first
or web show uh made for the internet is
on hbo.com I called at 3:00 a.m. it was
based on my experience at Comedy Central
cuz I pitched for them to the 3:00 a.m.
spot so this I did this for about almost
4 years at 3 in the morning every
Tuesday night I would go out in New York
City and if you were out I'll just ask
you specifically if you were out at 2:
in the at 300 in the morning on a
Tuesday night probably something good
was not happening right right like so
that was always the case I go not a
Saturday night cuz everyone's having a
party whatever but a Tuesday night why
aren't you asleep why aren't you getting
ready for school why aren't you getting
ready for work something wrong was
happening and so I did this for four
years almost interviewing people at 3 in
the morning and then I would uh get the
transcript we would do design around it
and put four interviews a week from 1996
through 1999 on hbo.com and I really
love doing it and I suppose that was
like in in a weird way the first podcast
in a in a sense so we were always doing
creative things for every company and I
enjoyed that part but I didn't enjoy
clients because clients will call me up
also at 3 in the morning and tell me
their problems and their issues and and
I just didn't enjoy it and you have to
and so I I sold the company as as fast
as I could but I didn't again I didn't
really there's a lot of subtleties to
valuing and selling a business people
think oh you build something and then
somebody offers you a ton of money and
you say yes and that's that but that's
not how it works so entrepreneurship is
building a company and learning how to
get profitable or raise money or
whatever I we were always very
profitable so perhaps that was a mistake
maybe I should have raised money to
build something much bigger uh and lose
money in the process because those
companies were getting sold for much
bigger amounts because then you're
selling the dream as opposed to selling
a profitable income stream but the big
mistake I made was I thought it was so
good that that we were profitable what I
should have done was I should have said
you know what I'm a software guy I can
make software products to help people
build websites so secretly I was making
software to help me quickly build
websites so americanexpress.com was like
60,000 pages and so I built software to
help me quickly generate 60,000 pages
and have uh communication between all
the employees American Express to help
me analyze the the new site and and
where the troubleshoot and I had all
these products I was developing I didn't
tell anyone because I didn't want them
to think we weren't working that many
hours so they would pay us less American
Express paid us $250,000 when I had zero
in the bank they were one of our first
big clients and we were looking at each
other they're going to pay us $250,000
to do this website so I wrote what
software to build the website we built
the website in a day but didn't tell
them and what I should have done if I
was a smart business guy was say this is
a product we're selling you a product
and I should have been A Product Company
when you're a Service Company the saying
is all your assets go out the door when
the light you know at the end of the day
because it's the people are your assets
when you're a product company you make
money while you sleep and it's worth a
lot more it's worth a 100 million
instead of 6 million and I didn't
understand anything about business about
valuation about how Wall Street values
companies because that's ultimately at
the end of the day that's how they're
going to value your company I didn't
understand how to build long-term
relationships with with clients so I was
not really this is my very first
business I was I had no business
experience at all I didn't study
business I'd been writing fiction for
years and before that a computer
programmer before that a nerdy chess
player I had a lot of girlfriends in in
high school obviously
and you know then uh uh we sold the
business stock went up so I did sell
sell out with a decent amount but then
again like I said I lost everything in a
very short period cuz I didn't know any
there's three skills making money
keeping money growing money so I made
money but I didn't know that there was
these other skills called keeping money
and growing money and even making money
I was okay at it but not great and you
could say I was great but I could say I
could have been much better if I knew a
little bit more about business so like I
said I thought I'd won the lottery and
this is never going to happen again and
I don't know anything I'm never going to
be able to do this again and I just lost
it all and had been spoiled I didn't
want to go back to a job and not that I
was too snobby for a job but I was just
depressed and I had my I had two little
daughters one was three the other was
zero and I said to myself there I was I
was so horrified at what I had done I
was losing my house so I had one of the
things I had spent on as I bought a big
apartment in New York City and rebuilt
it not knowing what I was doing doing at
all even doing that and I was going to
lose my house I owed money in taxes and
I had no money so so I thought I I my
mind always went to the worst case
scenario of what was going to happen
there and I had these two babies but I
had one thing left which is I had a life
insurance policy that I had bought when
I had money so I figured look my
three-year-old and my zerye old they're
not going to remember me their mom my my
ex-wife will be able to remarry and so I
started alav Vista that was the search
engine alav Vista I started alav Vista
in what is the best way to kill yourself
without hurting yourself because I
didn't want to hurt myself and and also
I had life insurance policy I didn't
want anybody to suspect that I killed
myself because then maybe I didn't know
the rules maybe you could wouldn't get
your life insurance policy turns out
there's no way to do it both those
things hurting yourself or preventing
people from finding out so I didn't go
through with that but we lost the house
I kind of went into Exile I was so
depressed I couldn't leave my room we
moved 70 miles away in the middle of a
blizzard to this kind of sort of almost
rural area and I just had nothing to do
I had no jobs no opportunities no
friends because when you when you make a
lot of money everybody becomes your
friend when you lose it all nobody's
your friend anymore and that applies to
everybody you know you don't know
anybody at once you lose all the money
so I really didn't know anybody I had no
opportunities and I was just so
depressed I couldn't leave my house and
so I figured okay my compass was
starting to move again and I figured I
made I lost so much money investing it's
because I didn't know anything I didn't
I didn't do what I normally do when I
study something when I studied computers
and the internet I had a methodology for
getting to be not only good getting to
be not only good but among the best even
when I was a kid and I started getting
interested in a game just a simple game
like chess I had a methodology for
getting better you divide up you divide
a big skill into all the micro skills
and you take lessons from a really great
coach and you apply yourself in
professional tournaments and that's how
you get good at a skill that's kind of
the basics of how you get a good at a
skill so I I did that with a game like
chess I did that with computers I did
that with understanding the internet but
I had never done that with Investing For
some reason and so I I read hundreds and
I'm not even exaggerating I read
hundreds of books un investing and I
still felt like I didn't quite grasp
what was going on because I didn't
understand the psychology I was I had
almost had PTSD from losing all this
money so I would buy a stock and if it
moved for one second against me I'd have
a panic attack so using my computer
background I wrote software to I took 60
years of stock market data for every
single stock and I wrote software I had
an artificial intelligence background I
wrote software to sort of model the
stock market and taking what I learned
from all the great investors of the past
I tried to model what they would think
but within software and then I found all
these patterns within the stock market
and so then I started trading slowly bit
by bit uh with just the little money I
had left I I you know when we F when the
we finally sold the house had tiny tiny
bit of money left not enough to survive
but enough to put in the market and try
to make some money and it worked so I
was trading every day and the software
was basically making money every single
day but now I didn't know any investors
I didn't know anybody in the investment
Community I never worked on Wall Street
I didn't know anybody at any bank so I
wrote all these people all these Heroes
of mine new Heroes who were investment
Gods I I wrote to each one of them and I
said hey can I buy I'm a big fan man can
I buy you a cup of coffee and pick your
brain and I got zero responses it's not
like somebody would say no I just nobody
responded it's not what what is going to
happen is Warren Buffett gonna suddenly
say glattus hold all calls someone named
James aler is gonna fly to Omaha treat
me to a 60 Cent cup of coffee and pick
my brain that I've of all the knowledge
I've amassed over the past 60 years of
investing he's not going to do that
nobody did that so then I started
thinking of something else I started
saying well you know I need to do
something that's going to attract their
attention I need to be more creative and
so since this is since 2002 I always
carry around a waiter pad and every
single day and this is every single day
since 2002 I write down 10 ideas a day
and the reason is people always say
ideas are dime a dozen execution is
everything this also is the worst advice
ever
ideas are not a dime a dozen a good idea
is very hard and the creativity is a
muscle just like any other muscle if you
got into an accident and you were in bed
in a hospital bed for two weeks your leg
muscles would atrophy you would need
physical therapy to walk again and all
of us we're walking around all day long
with our creativity muscles atrophied so
I started writing down 10 ideas a day
and it have to be like a like the the
topic would could vary it could be 10
business ideas 10 ideas for you 10 ideas
how Amazon could be better so I I
started researching each person I wanted
to meet and I would write I'd study them
enough and study their business I'd
write 10 ideas for them and so then I
sent each one of the 20 an email again I
said I don't need to meet you uh uh
here's 10 ideas for your
business you know see you later enjoy
and other 20 people three people wrote
back to me uh one person I had sent
literally 10 software programs I I said
I know based on reading your PhD thesis
you're very much interested in this
style of quantitative programming so I
wrote this software I'll teach your
employees how to use it or not and good
luck another person was a a not only a
hedge fund manager but a a big writer
about finance and I said here's 10
articles you if you wrote these articles
I would love to read them you never have
to contact me again I just I think you
would do a great job writing these
articles I came with 10 ideas for
articles that he should write that were
very unique kind of Articles another
person I also gave 10 ideas to and those
were the only three people who responded
out of the 20 the first person after
several month getting to know each other
period he invested money with me so he
became my first investor and I started a
hedge fund and he was a professional
hedge fund manager so using the fact
that he was a qualified hedge fund
manager investing in me I raised other
money and suddenly I had I was in the
hedge fund business with the other
person who was a writer he said these
ideas are great I don't want to write
them though how about you write them so
he hired me to be a writer for his very
popular website it was the street.com it
was Jim Kramer and so suddenly I was a
writer and the third person I figured oh
I've got these two I won't respond to
him and then but 12 years later I hit
reply on his email and I said 12 years
12 years so in 2014 this is 2002 I wrote
these emails 2014 I rep I literally hit
reply and I said to him he he had
written to me okay I'll meet you for
lunch I I wrote to him I replied in 2014
and I said okay but instead of lunch do
you want to come on my podcast so that's
when Nim TB author of many great books
uh came on my podcast and I started a
career in finance and investing after
losing all my money investing but at
this point I I'd read hundreds of books
I um had written all the software and
because I had no background in investing
it gave me a a kind of a blank slate
view so instead of just studying you
know value investing or growth investing
I studied everything from merger
Arbitrage convertible Arbitrage options
trading all the different styles of
options trading of course value
investing I would read these huge books
on accounting so I could read balance
sheets of from SEC filings like I didn't
know what I needed to know so I would
just try to learn everything and I was
so varied that then I started going on
CNBC because they knew I could talk
about any topic if Microsoft had
earnings I could analyze them uh if if
the Fed was Raising interest rates I
could analyze what it meant historically
if housing was going into a bubble I
could compare it to is this like the
tool of bubble I knew all the history of
these things I had even written software
analyzing the price fluctuations of
tulips from hundreds of years ago just
to understand them a little better and
so I really became in informed on
investing so then a publisher I reached
out to and Wy was publishing a lot of
Finance books so I started writing books
for them I basically shared all my
software I one of the first book then I
wrote a book about Warren Buffett how he
was much more of a day trader than
people thought I just wrote all these
like crazy books about investing that
were very offbeat and you know
everything kind of cycled into each
other so more people would invest in the
fund I I started writing for the
financial times in the Wall Street
Journal I I became a spokesperson for
Fidelity for a while I started speaking
for them at conferences and I build this
this interesting career investing so but
so let me ask some question so you you
obviously turned a a weakness into a
strength yeah but so there's a couple of
of of questions I have with this story
which I find fascinating first one is
this uh so you're depressed right and
you're Su suicidal
you just won a lottery and then lost all
your winnings and then you decide okay I
have to go learn about this and your
self-study which seems to be you know
kind of your way all the time because it
was all selfstudy I knew nobody I
couldn't call anybody there was no one
to call I didn't even know who who would
I call I didn't know any other investors
at all so what was the psychological
inflection point though cuz you're now
you you're basically you you got reused
you you went away and got reused what
point did you finally say was it just
sheer survival motivation that got you
to start moving again or there there was
a little bit of that I had children and
I was going as far as I knew I was going
homeless like I didn't know what was
going to happen so I was scared and I'm
not even exagger like if if every day
you're in the fetal position crying for
12 hours a day you're not going to be
able to help your family
and
action crowds out depression mhm and so
I would I started taking these walks and
one time I was walking past the Bowery
in New York City which is there's this
toll strip of the Barry which is all
these restaurant supply stores and I
don't know I just wandered into one of
them and I got fascinated with just the
form factor the design of a waiter pad I
just loved it because you can't by the
way everybody should get a waiters pad
and I'll tell you why not only could you
write 109 as a day down and it's a good
format for that because there's if have
a big notebook there's too much
incentive to write a a paragraphs this
is just bullet points idea after idea
after idea you can't fit you you're not
writing a novel on a waiter pad the
other thing is if I'm going let's say
I'm raising money as a hedge fund or
even as a startup business I go to a
meeting a conference room everybody's
coming in in suits they all pull out
their I don't know how you say it the
mol skin the mol skin a uh notebooks
it's $500 notebooks they throw on the
ground and they really expensive pens
and then I just throw out my waiter's
pad on the table and 100% of the time
this I am not kidding 100% of the time
one person in the room will say I'll
take fries with that burger I don't know
why they always came up with that it was
just that was the joke every single time
someone would make and I would have
different answers but then they would
say why you have a waiter pad and I
would say it's 10 cents a pad I'm Frugal
and so they know they know that even
though I'm the one who just blew $15
million they knew uh or I was Frugal as
opposed to all of them with their $500
notebooks and their suits and everything
so it was con they they they felt for me
they was conversation starter and I
became you know the center of the
meeting which was my goal because I was
raising money but then I so I bought
these I bought a 100 Raiders pads for
$10 for some reason and the next day I
go out and I make my first list I came
up with a book idea and I wrote 10
chapters for the book and I got excited
for the first time in like a year I was
like excited like I'm going to write
this book and the title was how to beat
your friends at every game in the
universe cuz when you go home for
Thanksgiving you're with your friends
and your family you eat your turkey and
then someone pulls out a Monopoly board
or Scrabble or cards for poker or Bridge
or Checkers or chess and for every one
of these games I was like a game
expert so for every one of these games I
knew how how to win with a with a
shortcut I'll give you an example
Scrabble most people think you need a
really good vocabulary it's actually the
worst way to win a Scrabble it's very
hard to have a very good vocabulary good
enough to win a Scrabble but there's
easier ways you this if I just told you
all of the two-letter words you would
beat all of your friends and family at
Scrabble and then throw in the Q without
you words like Q a t qop PF QA n a Qi
and then you're guaranteed to win
because this a hard Qi is hard to get
rid of and I just told you how but if
you also know the two letter words you
knew x i XU uh Za these are words that
are not AA is a legal word then you
learn like odd words are just all
consonants or you words like e DH so
it's just like three T tips and so let
me ask you this CU you are obviously a
very very unique individual right I mean
most people aren't like you I think you
know that you you have a a different
form of intelligence a different way of
viewing the world which has driven all
these actions yeah so you through this
experience I'd say wow you found a way
to create success you know in your
unique way I mean not many people are
walking in the into restaurant supply
stores and buying you know uh waiter
pads and saying the for this is perfect
to create ideas and right it's and this
is this is genius the question I have
though is are there fundamental
principles that you've learned based on
your experience because you've had some
very tough experiences that are
applicable to us mere mortals over here
yeah and and by the way I am the mest of
The Mortals what happened where I built
a company sold it made millions and lost
everything happened to me four times in
a row over the next 10 years where I
built a company made it between 1 and 10
million depending on the company and
then lost every dime of it every dime
and I so you did it three more times
after that first one yeah three maybe
four I I try not to remember it all I
remember one time I was like again I had
done everything stupid I had built a
company sold it for 10 million bought
two houses right next to each other and
had a hammock right between the houses
and I was lying in the
hammock dead broke this was about again
about 8 months after IID sold the
company and I was dead broke and it
started raining and I'm like I just was
too depressed to get out of this hammock
and you you can't really get out of a
hammock anyway unless someone's helping
you and and I thought to myself man did
this really happen again like I am so
tired of doing this like I can't I don't
have the energy anymore to do this and
and and it was
I felt so sorry for myself and I was
also getting a divorce I was losing
these houses I mean literally the IRS
had boarded up these houses and I was
lying in this hammock and so finally I
said to myself well what what worked for
me on the way up each time and what was
what was I doing wrong on the way down
and I wanted to make it as simple as
possible and I had read at this point
also every self-help book they weren't
really working for me they're like it's
like getting a vitamin B injection in
the morning like it kind of holds you
through the day and then you're dep you
know then you're dead at night and so no
nothing was helping me and so I just
decided what what am I doing what is
going wrong here so I realized on the
way up each time there were it happened
to me so many times I didn't even need
to do a scientific experiment I was the
scientific experiment I had I was
statistically significant all by myself
so so what was going right for me on the
way up was that I was basically taking
care of myself in four different ways
and ever since then at night I will
check the box did I do these four things
and so and I got very esoteric how I
analyzed this but just the basics is was
I was I physically healthy was I was I
doing something to make myself
physically healthy and taking care of
myself because if the extreme is if
you're sick in bed you're not going to
come up with ideas and you're not going
to execute on them execution being as
important as ideas because execution is
is a subset of ideas many PE there's a
spectrum of execution you can execute
poorly or you can execute well and you
need to have good execution ideas to
execute well so anyway if you're sick in
bed you can't do that so I do everything
I can to be as healthy as possible I'm
not I don't always eat as well as I
could uh but I try always to be as
better than or or do activities that
were a little healthier than the day
before so that's physical emotional I
wanted to be around good people who I
loved who loved me back and as easy as
that sounds I hadn't been doing that and
I don't think I don't want to say most
people don't do it I don't want to judge
but just judging when I started writing
about this and judging from the
responses I got a very typical email I
would get was I got in bed with the
wrong Partners I just found out my
husband was cheating on me and now I'm
going through this ugly divorce so I
don't have time to to start a business
so if you're not emotionally taking care
of yourself and your relationships
you're not going to have energy to start
a business and to succeed or to be great
at something to to master a skill
whatever creativity you know writing
these 10 ideas a day that very first
time I did it I felt excited it's like
new neurons were connecting in my brain
and that was on day one after 6 months
of doing it I literally felt like this
waiter pad was like a superpower and the
neurons were were firing constantly for
instance I mentioned that first time I
was losing that first house and I lived
three blocks from ground zero so not
while I had got was going broke 911 also
happened and it was a crime scene you
couldn't I couldn't sell the house so
while I was going broke living in one of
the most expensive Apartments
unfortunately in New York City which was
hard to maintain the FBI was not letting
people visit my house I couldn't sell
the house and and it was horrible
obviously 9911 was much worse than my
problem selling a house but still I
couldn't sell the house so finally even
that creativity like starting we I
started figuring out how to sell my
house like every I I started to feel
like you could just drop me off in the
desert and I will figure my way out just
because everything was firing off
everything was inspiring me to be
creative does every human being possess
the capacity for creativity absolutely
so it's inherent
yeah I mean I think I had practiced a
little bit my sales technique was to
basically be creative for the client so
I was practicing already some creativity
but not and but when I got depressed I
had lost all my creativity and but but
writing 10 ideas a day down and making
yourself really sweat I always know I've
got a good list if by item number seven
I'm counting have I hit 10 yet I can't
come up with three more and I pushed
myself the so this is not waiting for
ins spiration this is discipline you
cannot wait for inspiration so it's
basically I got to do 10 and if I'm not
feeling creative I have to put myself I
have to flex that muscle basically every
single day I will do it now I haven't
done it every single day but I'll get to
that in a second but when going up when
things are going right physical
emotional creative I have to work on all
those and then what I'll call spiritual
but I don't mean it like in the way of
you know it's a fill-in the blanks kind
of spiritual in the sense that um um you
have to recognize what items in your
life you can't control and what you
can't control because again everything
is about energy if I spend too much time
wondering why did this client reject me
or why does this person not like me why
did they not return my calls why did
they stop talking to me or why did this
newspaper cancel my column or this
publisher not accept my book or this
investor not invest if I spend too much
time worrying about the things I can't
control I won't have energy to maximize
the things I can't control so oddly I
will put that in the spiritual category
and so so I've almost viewed it as four
separate bodies the physical body
emotional body Creative Body spiritual
body and just like you might have a
heart attack in your physical body if if
your blood's cut off I sort of imagined
in my mind there was this invisible
blood going back and forth between all
four bodies and if you were blocked or
stuck in any one of these bodies you'd
get a heart attack
a metaphorical heart attack and you
wouldn't be the optimal person to that
that succeeds and life somewhat
competitive to succeed you need I I
needed everything working smoothly I
needed no no stoppages of or blockages
of of this invisible blood between the
physical emotional creative and
spiritual bodies so every day today
yesterday at the end of the day I just
check did I do something for myself that
is 1% better on my
physical emotional did I improve a
relationship did I do something for the
people I love did I cultivate a
friendship every relationship needs
watering to to bloom spiritual did I
really did I did I did I obsess too much
over things I can't control which is a
very common thing or common for me or
did I move forward and do the best I can
at the things I can't control so I
always make sure I check that box every
day and the times when I lost everything
I wasn't writing the 10 ideas a day down
so finally this is like 10 years into
this 2010 I decided you know what I
cannot go through this again again so
2010 2011 I was still living through
this it was like I was so stressed and
anxious I couldn't sleep cuz I had just
gotten broke again and I finally decided
okay I'm just going to do this now and
I'm never going to stop no matter what
whether I'm going broke whether I'm
getting rich and it's amazing what
happens if you do this while you're
losing money because it's it's a it
bounces you much faster is that so two
questions after the pain of going broke
the first time a second time Etc did it
doesn't get better you no I imagine it
gets worse even gets worse because how
could I have done this again and I
learned something that a lot of people
think it gets better oh you really good
now knowing when you go broke that
you'll be able to bounce back no all I'm
seeing is evidence that I'm broke and
that is probably going to get worse from
here oh that's got to play mind games I
mean now it's like you know now you
start worrying about you know do I just
bad luck at Bad Karma what what's going
on here but wouldn't you was there not
some piece of you because you're
obviously extremely bright that said you
know now that I've made this money I'm
going to safeguard at least some little
chunk of it to have a safety net should
my risks that I take not work out you
how' that not occur to you after a
couple times well I would say it
occurred to me after four or five times
Why didn't it occur to me after the
first time going broke I don't know why
did it not occur to me after the second
time I have no idea why did it not occur
to me after the third time after the
fourth time I have no idea so now there
had to be a blind spot somewhere right
yeah so now the theme of the series is
wealth breakthrough what was your wealth
breakthrough so was it discovering to
for things or what was it the wealth
break through was that no matter what is
happening physical emotional creative
spiritual 1% better each day of those
four bodies and I know that sounds
almost simplistic and I and I'm not
mentioning money in that explanation but
I I'll tell you a story yes so there was
one time I was involved in a company
it's a billion Revenue company and I was
uh uh advising them and I had shares and
we were doing great we were growing
revenues and I had 9 million dollars
worth of stock in this company so I'm on
the set of this the series premiere of
the TV show billions you know this t on
Showtime so in season 3 I was an adviser
for the show but this was this was
before Showtime had even picked it up I
was just they were filming the first
episode the series premiere had never
been on the air and I had never seen a
TV show despite my years at HBO I never
really seen a whole episode of a show uh
being uh filmed and I went out to New
Jersey where they had mocked up this
fake hedge fund and one of my favorite
directors was directing the episode Neil
berer who had directed Limitless and
some other stuff and so I was asking
tons of questions I was fascinated and
then in the middle of the day I get a
phone call uh emergency board meeting uh
in 15 minutes and so I excused myself
went out into the parking lot and I
thought this is amazing the only way
this could be an emergency board meeting
is we got an offer to sell the company
and I'm going to cash I'm going to
finally be able to cash out of this $9
million worth of stock this is going to
be amazing this is going to be the best
day of my life get on the board meeting
and the CEO says listen I have some news
our largest shareholder he just
disclosed to us he owes $90 million in
back taxes to the IRS that goes in
default of our debt agreement with the
bank uh the bank is on their way over
right now they're going to kick us out
and lock the doors and they're going to
basically divide up the company into
regions and sell each region to you know
they had millions of customers they had
customers like my company they were
going to sell for a dollar or to get
their money back they were going to sell
each region to a different one of their
customers for almost nothing and I
instantly kicked into gear I've been
doing this creative I've been building
my creative muscles for years so I just
started going through it like I'll buy
I'll buy the company before they get to
the door I didn't have the money doesn't
matter ready fire aim was my policy I'll
say I'll buy the company I'll make 20
calls and I'll find the money and
they're like no no they're on their way
over it's it's too late and I said how
about we sell some of the regions and
I'll make the calls to other companies
we'll sell and we'll raise back their
debt we only owed them a small amount of
debt but and they're like no no all the
competitors are already got the call
from them they're going to be able to
buy our company for nothing and came up
with 10 ideas right there on the call
and they were laughing even even though
they were all their lives were all going
down the drain they're like James all
the ideas are good but it's just a done
deal it's over it's like get off the
call and that was it I had just lost in
that 15 minutes $9 million but I don't
count this as one of the times I went
broke even though it's pretty close that
was like the bulk of what I had been
working on and and then I'm sitting
there in the middle of New Jersey
there's nine hours left of shooting on
this episode I have no way of getting
home unless I call a cab or something
and then what what was I going to do at
home I was I was just going to get
depressed so I just went back in there
and enjoyed the rest of the day I was
learning how to make a TV show this was
like a dream of mine and I loved the
show even before it had ever aired and
the writers later told me uh I explained
a year later I explained what had
happened that day and they're like are
you kidding me we thought you would just
like were in the bathroom for a really
long time like you were back asking
questions for the rest of the day you
stayed till you were the last person to
leave uh uh we didn't think anything was
going on and that's because at that
point I had built up the fortitude
eating healthy being healthy healthy
emotionally being around people I loved
and who loved me um being as creative as
possible every day uh uh I had no
control over this situation so I
couldn't I didn't allow myself to obsess
over it I did have control over how I
was going to enjoy the rest of the day
so I didn't I made the most of the rest
of the day rather than just go home and
cry in the fetal position which would
have been my default years earlier and
was it bad for me yes but then I knew
okay I'll just sit down again be
creative and I'll come up with more
ideas and I'll see what other businesses
I'm involved in that I could hit the
accelerator on maybe to make an income
all right a little bit more right to to
keep myself going while I rebuild and so
by that point I I don't and like I said
I don't even consider that one one of
those times where I went broke that was
just part of the the process I even
thought to myself getting off that call
this is now an opportunity to really
test that this method works for me yeah
and I just focused it as that but again
I kind of always view these four pra
these four bodies in a completely
different way almost like my own
personal religion so let me ask you this
because now now this All Leads up to I
think an important question which is how
would you define wealth I Define wealth
as you're completely in line or you're
completely aligned with this inner
compass that tells you what you love
doing where you can do it how you can do
it and where you need to be right now to
do it and the way you keep keep that
instrument clean that Compass clean is
I'm always going to get back to these
four invisible bodies the physical
emotional creative spiritual every day
is a challenge right life's pretty hard
so some days I will obsess on something
I have no control over or some days I'll
be disappointed did oh that person
wasn't the friend I thought or some days
you know I won't be as creative you know
I'll have 10 bad ideas but at least I
wrote down the 10 ideas if you're
writing 10 ideas a day that's 3,650
ideas a year maybe one will be good the
compass the whole Compass really
integrates into this this this process
of these four things they're connected
but it's the thing that I see that I'm
sure you've observed is that yes so
we've gotten this amazing Arc of histor
you know that you've just told but it
started with you talking about being in
grad school and having a compass and
saying my compass you know was leading
me somewhere else that's been your
constant companion that you've
identified you know early on in your
life and I guess the difference is is
that sometimes I would lose track of
where the compass was pointing the lens
would be dirty um because I
wasn't keeping this invisible blood
between these four bodies you know
flowing as as well as possible and then
the compass would be unclear and that's
that was very important for me to
realize is that I can't really I would I
would always think money was the end and
so once I made the money chapter two of
being a human would begin and I can just
wipe my hands everything i' done before
to be a good human I don't have to do
anymore I got to this point of being a
good human now I could just do whatever
and that was just the wrong way to think
I would just instantly get punished for
that and and punished is the right word
I would punish myself in a weird way so
people always ask me what do you do with
the ideas afterwards do you keep them
around do you follow up on them uh the
next day like how do you keep track no I
I throw out the ideas every day because
you're not going to what am I going to
do come up with 10 great ideas that I'm
going to do every day no uh once in a
while something will stand out like oh I
kind of like that so the next day my
list will be 10 very simple execution
ideas on that one idea from a week
before and then maybe I'll do one of
those execution steps because that's
what I realized too also and this is
more related to the nuts and bolts of
building a business or or succeeding
with an idea but people say execution is
everything and they seem to think people
know what that means when they say
execution but I've seen five different
people take the same idea and execute
them differently
and sometimes the execution would be so
bad that there would be no conceivable
way this person could succeed as a
business as an idea whatever but then
sometimes the exact same idea I'd see
someone execute it flawlessly and that
will work and so so PE execution ideas
as I said before is a subset of ideas
you if you have an idea what are the
next steps is the question that's the
list for the next day you have to make
them good execution steps are they good
ideas maybe one of them is and then if
you want the next day you could try to
execute first off at any given point I
might have 30 halfway decent business
ideas but for various reasons I'm not
going to execute on them I'm not ready
yet to execute on them I don't have
certain abilities or connections to
execute on them but you always want to
figure out how can I test out an idea
and you want to figure out the simplest
and fastest way to test out an idea you
only know something is good if you do it
M you know everyone always says doing is
the only way to know right right and and
knowing is the only way to do so you
have to know a lot to do something but
then to but then to know if something is
a good idea or not you have to do the
idea and otherwise you'll never know so
the critical thing is you expend as
little energy as possible until you're
going to decide to really push yourself
on this idea and again let's call that
an experiment so part of my philosophy
of making money of living a creative
life of having fun is to ex experiment
with as many ideas as possible as much
as possible so what's an experiment I'll
give can I give you one example sure
this is a stupid dumb example but it was
an experiment I took the bestselling
book of all time 50 Shades of Gray and I
uh found like a Word document of it and
I I went on fiverr.com and I found some
random person in India for $10 who will
do this he I said take every word in
this book and replace it with a synonym
and I found another person on fiverr.com
and I said make a cover for me I changed
the title of 50 Shades of Gray to
another title but it sounded like 50
Shades of Gray a little bit and so now I
had within a few weeks I had a 500 page
completely new book that was exactly 50
Shades of Gray except 100% of the words
were different so instead of saying um
Julia had to rush back to her tests it
would say something like Shannon went as
quickly as possible back to her classes
for examinations and so every word is
different and I did that sentence by
sentence for 50 Shades of Gray I
uploaded it to Amazon which is all you
have to do to publish a book on Amazon
and to this day I still have this book
on Amazon under a pseudonym of course
and it actually sold 85 copies but it
has gotten no reviews cuz it's probably
hard I've never even read it has has no
reviews but that was an experiment that
also took me about an hour of my time
why not do an experiment like that just
to see what if it's sold as well as 50
Shades of Gray who knows so I'm doing
experiments constantly at any given
point I'm in like 10 different
experiments so what are your main
activities right now like so I see
you're still being being creative you're
you're running experiments like that
book what are your main activities now
uh so I have a podcast I've been doing
for six years and I interview Peak
performers in any industry and I love
doing that
because I love how did somebody learn to
be the best in the world at what they do
how did this race car driver learn to
become the best race car driver how did
Kem Abdul Jabar learn to be the best
basketball player there's plenty of
people who are 7 feet tall there's not
that many 7 feet tall people who are the
best basketball players in history how
did Richard Branson go from being a
music magazine publisher to the owner of
an airline and then a billionaire uh or
how did Sarah Blakeley go from selling
fax machines door to door not knowing
anything about the fashion industry to
having one of the biggest clothing
companies in the world or Tyra Banks go
from being a model to having the a a TV
show now in its 31st season so I'm
always fascinated how do people learn
how do people achieve Peak Performance
because I always I want to develop my
own methodology built on top of these
four bodies where you can continue to
whatever you're interested in and your
interests constantly change whatever
you're interested in I don't want to put
10,000 hours now into learning into
being great at something I want to find
out how the best in the world get to be
great and then I want to model that so I
can at least taste greatness as quick as
possible and so that's the podcast I
write books I've written 22 books at
this point um some of them have sold
299 copies and were horrible one of them
has sold over a million copies hopefully
more of them will get there and uh I
enjoy writing and I've experiment with
different different styles of writing
I've been writing almost every day since
1990 so I love exploring different
genres and and ways of writing and
points of view and so on uh I help run
different businesses I'm an active
investor I'm invested in over 30
businesses I I help run a business right
now involving you know Financial
newsletters and education and so on that
I hope helps people in ways that Wall
Street has abandoned people I own a
stand-up comedy club and I perform
anywhere from three to 10 times a week
this week I'm performing six times and I
I I help run that club that's my least
favorite activity I really just like
going on stage but during the day
sometimes I'll have to think of my
material and I'll watch other comedians
even for public speaking long before I
was doing standup I've been doing
standup comedy uh I'm in the fifth year
of doing that long before doing that
before I would give a public talk I
would always watch standup comedy
obsessively starting about 24 hours
before the talk because we have these
things in our brain called mirror
neurons so if you if you don't know how
to climb a ladder but you watch someone
climbing a ladder now you know how to
climb a ladder you don't you don't need
to do it you can your mirror neurons
have taught you how to do it as if you
were the one doing it and the same thing
for public speaking standup Comics are
the best public speakers so I'm going to
watch the best public speakers before I
talk and so I'll my mirror neurons will
still be firing and then I'll give the
talk and I'll have the benefit of of
that so so I've always been love stand
up comedy it's help me in other areas of
my life but I was too afraid to go on
stage now the past four or five years
I've been going on stage and it's it's
worked very well for me helps in every
other area of my life so being a chess
player has helped in every other area of
my life being for a small amount of time
a professional poker player has helped
in every other area of my life being an
entrepreneur has helped in other
areas being a comedian or a writer has
helped in other areas and so on so after
this amazing story of your life uh with
all the Lessons Learned along the way so
now here you are your early 50s are you
happy uh no I mean I don't like the word
happy I think if let's say I play a hand
of Poker and I win a lot of money in
that one hand you get this surge of
dopamine and right then I'm happy right
the happiness you you you get on a
dopamine hit is much better than General
everyday happiness but that's why you
dopamine is absorbed by the body within
seconds so it's a special kind of
happiness but people I think strive for
it too much you know you get it only so
many times before you get addicted to it
and but I think well-being is something
a little different and I I do think I
have a certain degree of of well-being
and I think that's what
you know being around people you love
doing what you love to do uh being
healthy you get kind of this satisfied
wellbeing you know cuz sometimes you
don't want to be happy sometimes for
instance a Melancholy and I actually
like that feeling as well I might miss
my kids if they're not around that's a
Melancholy feeling not a happy feeling I
think people are too addicted to you
know there's books happiness this
happiness that being happy all the time
uh is that's not an interest of mine is
it the maybe fulfillment no because I
don't know what's going to fulfill me
from day to day you know because I'm
always trying different things and you
know I think really it's just did I
follow my own process then I know I had
a good day and I always told myself the
best predictor of a good day tomorrow is
a good day today and I just try to
follow this process as much as I can and
sometimes I fail and so the goal is to
as consistently as possible keep to my
daily process do you know of any future
aspirations you have that uh you know
that you haven't done yet saying this is
something that I want to do in my life
that I haven't done yet yeah but like
random things I mean there's nothing cuz
I always know I'll I'll figure out each
day and it might be something completely
surprising and unusual like I never
thought I would be so interested in
doing stand-up comedy as an example I
loved it but I didn't think I would do
it and I I've never written a thriller
novel I kind of I've had a lot a lot of
Thriller writers on my podcast and I
always break down their process really
trying to understand and I read all
their books and then try to understand
and so I think I can make a stab at at
writing a thriller novel I'd like to do
that uh I definitely don't want to start
another business again yeah you're done
with that I hate
it and you don't need to start a
business to build wealth the average
multi-millionaire according to the IRS
not according to me has seven different
sources of income so a a job or being an
entrepreneur is just one source of
income so so I like to
invest in in a very small amounts of
money like a very small like I will
never invest more than 1% of my net
worth in any one investment but if an
investment takes off I'll make a lot of
money and if an investment fails I only
lost 1% of my net worth so I like
looking at small private companies to
invest in and uh I have a methodology
behind investing my number one role is
someone smarter than me has to be
investing alongside of me so I can never
think I am smart enough to invest in XYZ
genomics company or XYZ robotics company
or whatever it is if I see oh let's say
Warren Buffett is invested in a company
and I'm never going to say if I run into
him at a cocktail party I'm never going
to say Warren how could you have been so
stupid like to invest in that no I I
will just write the check I don't even
care what the company is here you go
Warren you take your own fee on it and
just give me the money when it makes
money and so I'm always with people
smarter than me I don't have to do that
much due diligence on the company and I
no longer advise companies cuz that was
very stressful like that $9 million
example so once a company calls me for
advice after I've invested I remove them
from my phone book because they they're
they're going out of business so um but
fortunately because I follow this advice
the the my co-investors have to be
smarter than me the CEO has to have
built and sold a similar company before
just those two rules and and there
should be some Revenue generation
already so he knows how to make money
and I know that he knows how to sell or
she knows how to sell a company because
they've done it in the past then I never
have to think about it again and so I'm
able to invest and not take too much
energy and conserve energy for doing the
things I love so incidentally I think
that that's genius investment strategy
it's because it's simple and I have
makes a ton of sense it works because
venture capitalist will always say oh
nine out of 10 companies will fail nope
I mean right now every single company
I've invested in is over what I say over
the hump meaning they're they're
doubling in revenues every year or
they're profitable or they no longer
need to raise money they're now deciding
should we wait one year five years or 10
years before we are big enough that we
sell or exit uh so this strategy works
extremely extremely well so you're
building your wealth now not through uh
running or starting a business but
through investing in other businesses
correct although I mean it's only
recently I built I I built a business I
started a business in 2015 in 2018 it
did 60 million in revenues but again I
knew I wasn't the person to run it so at
first I hired a CEO and a complete
management team and they all lived in
other cities I didn't want to live in
the same city you you know sold the
company but still I'm I I have an active
profit share with it so you know again I
use as little energy as possible to
create as much success as possible but I
don't think I'm going to do that again
I'm done with that except for owning a
comedy club
unfortunately the worst investment ever
that is not a good investment nobody
should buy a physical
space oh so you're talking about from
the real estate side or or the sector of
being in a comedy club or both both
who's going to buy a clothing store
that's a horrible idea yeah restaurant
is usually a bad idea yeah I'm a bar/
comedy club on a side street in the
upper west side it's in business and
it's it's doing it's treading water but
it's not going to it's not Uber but this
is for your own fulfillment right yeah
yeah so in that respect it's a good
investment because it brings you some
pleasure in your life yeah like I don't
own a home I don't buy a car uh I don't
own a boat so many of these things that
as people get get older and and have
some money they could spend they buy
other things that I don't like I bought
this for probably a cheaper price than
what other people spend on their houses
or their cars or their Yachts or
whatever or their vacation homes or or
their vacations period why don't you own
a home let me let me put frame it in a
different way would you ever say you
know what I really like Apple stock so
I'm going to put my entire net worth in
this one stock and then I'm going toy
borrow eight
500% I'm I'm going to take everything I
own and then I'm going to borrow five
times that and put it all into apple and
and I can't sell it when I most need it
you know that you would say to yourself
boy if someone said to you they were
going to do that you would say do not do
that that is the worst investment
strategy I've ever heard even if Apple
was a good stock and they're like no no
no trust me I'm going to I'm going to
borrow this money and Apple's going to
kill it and everybody does you would say
no you would never do so house is the
same thing just replace Apple by house
you put all most people put all their
the money they can afford into the down
payment then they borrow another 4 or
500% and then every year they have to
maint they spend extra money they didn't
account for to maintain the house to
take care of it to pay property taxes
which are always volatile and then let's
say they need to sell it they're
desperate to sell it you can't because
usually when you're desperate other
people are desperate and you can't sell
it's illiquid so it's worse than Apple
you can't sell it on a stock market you
sell it on a illiquid housing market so
house is just a horrible investment
think about why houses exist a factory
wants to wants to pay as little as
possible to its workers so hey we'll
lend you the money this is traditionally
100 years AG we'll lend you the money to
buy a house don't worry we want our
workers to be happy and so everyone is
forced to live around the factory and
you can't sell it so your your income
you're not mobile so you can't choose to
have a different job you're stuck with
this income so your income Mobility is
is more difficult like how's it housing
has never been a good idea housing could
be an investment but not in the US US is
a poor investment well so you know it's
interesting because uh I think it used
to be you're going to work in that job
in the factory for 30 years and retire
and during and mortgages would match the
time that you're going to be working
there so you pay off the house that's
kind of retirement but in today's uh
World it seems like a very different
scenario the average person changes jobs
every four years yeah so and a lot of
people are leaving the workplace because
of automation uh even though we're at an
a low the lowest unemployment rate in 50
years part of the reason for that is
that so many people have left the
workforce due to Automation and so
they're not counted in the employment
rates anymore they're on disability or
some other kind of program and uh they
no longer count towards the unemployment
rate so this is a problem systemically
right now how much automation will
affect
uh the labor force and levels of you
know well-being in the labor force it
hasn't totally hit yet but it's one of
those things that's going to hit very
soon and so it's just something to be
careful of well I feel like I could talk
to you for about a week and uh and still
get fresh new stories and information
from you but uh this has been a really
fascinating Journey well thank you for
having me on this this this series and
this show and uh yeah I skipped over a
lot of stories but that's that's fine I
think I got to the the meaty ones I'll
ask you one I'll ask you one final
question because this was related to my
very first idea list how do you beat
your friends and family at Monopoly do
you know the answer um no get the orange
properties you know like uh Tennessee St
James New York Avenue and and I'll tell
you why the mo what's the most commonly
you know how to play Monopoly yes do you
know the most commonly landed Square in
Monopoly um I don't which one jail cuz
you can go to jail by Landing there on
the dice you can land on the go to jail
square and there's two Community chest
cards that make you go to jail so jail
is going to be the most commonly landed
on card the most common dice roll of two
dice is seven seven puts you right in
the middle you know six through eight
put you right in the middle of the
orange properties so if you own all the
hotels on the orange properties that's
going to be the most common properties
people land on you'll just clean up now
just beat your for anybody you want at
Monopoly well that now we're going to
have a bunch of people that run out and
go pull out their blow the dust off
their Monopoly boards and say let me
play this game again now I'm going to
beat everybody that's okay I have I have
one other trick which I'll tell you
after the show's over so you can beat
them okay great I get some inside
information now James it's been really
really a joy to be with you today thanks
so much thanks so much I really
appreciate it we are so excited about
the momentum that's building from wealth
breakthroughs it's actually beyond our
expectations and I want to give a
special thank you for those of you who
already jumped in and bought the series
it means a lot to us it tells us that
it's adding value to your life and it
also supports this work so we can
continue to do it and get this
information out to the world so people
everywhere can have their wealth
breakthrough so thank you so very
[Music]
much hope you enjoyed that interview
with James James is the classic big idea
swing for the fence's wealth
breakthrough story now let's switch
gears did you know there's a strong case
why you should avoid retirement plans
like 401ks and IRAs did you know John D
Rockefeller built much of his fortune
using one little known secret and do you
know there are just four Investments
preferred by the 1% that are 100%
guaranteed to hand you reliable returns
any of those three questions grab your
attention I bet they all did well
unpacking the mysteries of wealth
figuring out what makes it flow towards
some people and away from others how to
be smarter about money in ways big and
small every day and showing folks how to
break the chains of the 9-to-5 life is
the specialty of Garrett Gunderson he's
one of my favorite people on Earth to
talk to about money and wealth and we're
pleased to present his new interview to
you here in episode four of wealth
breakthroughs so Garrett when I think
about the idea of having a wealth
breakthrough uh you're the first person
that comes to my mind and for good
reason because uh how many years I've
known you and uh and my experience the
first time I met you and how radical a
thinker you were in this realm had a
massive impact on me so uh I'm really
excited to have this particular
conversation me too I always like our
conversations yeah they lead somewhere
don't they somewhere somewhere
productive so let's start with you first
as far as your kind of trajectory you
know what was your upbringing how' you
end up doing the type of work you're
doing well look I I grew up in a coal
mining town I mean my great-grandfather
left San Giovani Italy left his family
behind for seven years became a goat
herder and eventually a coal miner and
it took him that seven years to save up
enough money to have a house and afford
to get them over to the United States so
that that creates a lot of scarcity and
then my grandfather's were coal miners
my father was a coal miner so I came
from a very blue collar background where
the belief was if you just work hard
enough everything's going to work out
but the reality was it didn't right
Minds went on strike there were mind
disasters things like that so when I was
15 I was playing sports and in school
and I want to have a job to have some
extra money but it was a little hard to
do in navigate Sports so I actually
started my first official business
detailing cars so I just clean cars my
dad being a coal miner bring home the
surface vehicles for the bosses I'd
clean those up my mom worked in a credit
union they'd repossess the vehicles I'd
clean them up so they could sell them
for more and I started winning uh young
entrepreneur competitions and that came
with money and I wanted to invest that
money now my mom being the Italian that
she was her money management method was
put money in a coffee can put it in the
seller and you don't ever give anyone
else that money right so there's just
all this accumulation scarcity pinching
pennies type of mentality so when I was
like I want to invest she wouldn't sign
off wow so you had as a teenager I guess
you had some money what kind of money
were we talking about oh look man I was
more in like the millionaire Nextdoor
mindset when I was a teenager I thought
if I just never spent money I could
accumulate a lot so uh the first year in
business which was about eight months
total I think I made $600 of net income
but then I won $500 for taking third
place for the rural young entrepreneur
the second year I took first it came
with 1,000 bucks and then I won it for
the estate which came with $5,000 and
Statewide Championship you went on this
Statewide so Governor's young
entrepreneur and I remember getting
handed that $5,000 check and thinking
that was a lot of money yeah and I was
like oh man I'm going to invest this
money that's a big time and it I didn't
realize it was just a drop in the bucket
it didn't really matter in the grand
scheme of things but it at least got me
thinking it had me asking different
questions had me going in interviewing
the wealthiest people that I knew which
to me at the time was who had the
biggest homes that that was basically
the mindset I was in at that age so uh
then off to college what was next yeah I
did go to college um I had a scholarship
I went to Southern Utah University a
small college but fortunately I became a
senator there and the year I became a
business Senator um for the college this
guy Steve harup showed up and he was
going to be a professor and so he had
managed money for 25 years and ended up
managing $5 billion of strong
Investments at the time it was the
number two Investment Company in the
world as far as performance and ranking
and he just decided his next 25 years he
was going to pay it forward so I greeted
him when he came on board I ended up
getting to know him a little bit found
out he wanted to work out so I became
his rball partner but after rall we'd go
get a yogurt and we' just sit down and
talk and ask him a lot of questions and
at that same time I was doing an
internship June of 1998 in the financial
industry and when the market started to
go down in 2000 he became instrumental
and me facing all my clients and saying
I don't know what the hell I'm doing
you're invest in the market I don't know
how long this is going to last on a
downturn uh telling you you're in it for
the long haul doesn't sound like the
right thing telling you the markets on
salees seems insulting because you've
already got your money in and it's going
down so we save people hundreds of
thousands it would have been Millions
but I was pretty young at the time and
then in the year 2000 one in 2002 my
clients did 44% positive return and 41%
positive return and they were out of the
market 80% of the time and that's where
my financial Journey really began when
you had that sort of um I guess call
Epiphany or you got to see you know how
the difference of performance uh in
those two years uh what did you start
thinking like how did that affect your
decisions about what you want to do with
your life well the way it really
affected me was in the year 2000 because
I went from being this little Financial
Einstein of my community a town of
12,000 people and a lot of them I'm
become they're becoming my clients
simply because no one's really talking
to them I'm having them cash in double e
bonds and put it in mutual funds and
yeah 98 99 everyone's making money now
the market goes down a lot of my clients
are family members so family reunions
become more Awkward than normal right so
I'm showing up and they're like what's
going on and that's when I had to tell
them I didn't know what I was doing and
that's when I went on a journey for 26
straight months flying somewhere once a
month spending anywhere from two days to
a full week and I was just interviewing
people I leveraged my age see when
you're 19 years old almost anyone will
talk to you because they want to pay it
forward right so I didn't have to write
a check to get that mentorship I just
asked questions and I had a little red
memo pad I would flip and I had all
these questions I'd ask them I'd go meet
with actuaries I'd go meet with fund
managers I'd go meet with people that
were working with and Advising people on
Wall Street and I just got a huge
Awakening during that time of what was
really going on because I saw people
that worth $20 million and they sold
stocks but they had less than 5% of
their portfolio in stocks and so that
was kind of shocking and then I went and
saw a family office for the first time
which is a group that essentially the
client wasn't even there but this guy
was presenting a $400 million
transaction and it was all these people
doing real due diligence I wrote a book
what would the Rockell do and what the
Rockefellers did to create generational
wealth was they actually hired Financial
professionals that just worked for their
family so the rockfeller had their own
group of accountants and attorneys and
investment advisers and fiduciaries and
risk management Specialists that help
manage their entire family wealth and so
hence family office now in today's world
these family offices it means you're
Under One Roof and you've got this
entire team of professionals but they
might manage 10 20 or 100 families and
so when I saw that I was like this is
phenomenal how does this work because
the client wasn't even in the room right
they weren't even past that stage to
bring the client in to say here's
something we think you should consider
and I just saw that their first EMP
emphasis was how can we be tax efficient
how can we be tax efficient because
that's a guaranteed return and my
question changed from where should we
invest to what are the guarantees in
finance and I found there were four
areas that you could have a guaranteed
return what are they all right so the
first one is saving on tax MH the
majority of the population is overpaying
on tax and with all the tax law changes
it's almost everyone including me I I
think about it all the time but I just
got what's called a d-pad credit because
I'm you know creating books and all this
stuff and I say go back three years and
amend those returns because of d-pad or
section 199 and get that Amendment right
see because I'm constantly asking these
questions I'm constantly bringing new
people into my life and I know what
conversations to have with them so the
second one is interest there's a lot of
ways you can save interest whether it's
you reallocate so let's say that you
have an underperforming asset like a
certificate of deposit or a bond or
something like that and then you have a
loan that you're paying more interest
than what you're earning why not cash
that thing out pay it off and it's a
guaranteed return
or you can restructure the loan right if
you have collateral like a car you could
refinance a car and pay off other loans
that might be double that interest rate
and all of a sudden car loan improves
your credit score improved credit score
might allow you to refinance a mortgage
and refinance that Mortgage in today's
interest rate environments will save you
a boatload of cash so you can
restructure you could reallocate or you
could renegotiate all loans are
negotiable and if you know how to have
that conversation and how to set
yourself up to look good to the banks
and institutions you can lower the
interest rate so we got you know the IRS
then we've got Interest next is
Investments Investments are riddled with
hidden fees hidden commissions
non-performing fees and if you can
discover where those are you can boost
your returns substantially now it seems
like it would be incremental because if
I told you hey you could earn 9.2% or
10% that doesn't sound really big but
it's logarithmic so think about if you
had 100 Grand over 30 years that 100
Grand could grow to 1.74 million at 10%
at 99.2% it grows to 1 4 million that's
$340,000 from what seem to be
inconsequential costs right the other
big part on investments is people just
participate in the downturn when they
don't need to they can create measures
and structures to cash out sit in cash
and then when everyone else loses they
can buy and make money on the buy the
fourth place is Insurance there's
duplicate coverages there's improper
structure and all you really have to do
is say how can you Ure the catastrophic
and not the inconsequential so you give
the insurance companies less money and
you only ensure the things that would
actually derail harm you and there's a
lot of money that you can put back into
your pocket while still protecting
yourself so from a categoric standpoint
what makes this really interesting is a
lot of times people are saying how can I
invest in what kind of return can I get
but literally the kind of return they're
trying to get uh you know it could be
gained just by getting more efficient in
all those four categories you just
mentioned so inside of what would the
rock flowers do we did the study we said
what if someone had a million dollars to
invest and we can take a zero off and
make it a 100,000 or we can add a zero
make it 10 million the number isn't as
important but we said what if you had a
million dollars what rate of return
would you have to earn if you're in a
standard situation where you have two
loans right where you have a business or
even a side hustle um what would you
have to earn on that money in order to
equate what it would take if we went
through those four eyes of the IRS
interest Investments and insurance and
just remove the drag and keep more of
what you make and the rate of return
would have to be 44% wow or it would
have to be taxfree at like 30% right or
29% that's extraordinarily hard to get
Warren Buffett's at 22% R Doo maybe is
getting those numbers but the majority
of the population isn't and by the way
they're taking unnecessary risk to try
to get that higher return and a lot of
times it doesn't pan out and that's hard
to sustain that for year after year
maybe a business can grow 50% one year
but we're not going to see the major
players like apple double in size over a
year right or double their stock value
so these are the things that are so
essential because if you could be more
efficient you get a win right now mhm if
you go those four eyes if you can make
money on the buy which was another thing
when I said we got really high rates of
return while sitting in cash there's an
entire philosophy that when we're in
distressed economies those people with
cash are King right now the wealthiest
families in America have 36% of their
Assets in cash and cash equivalents well
everyone else is being taught to be
fully deployed and allocated into
retirement plans that are ill liquid
that they couldn't get that cash if they
wanted to so being in cash means you
have negotiating power when people need
to liquidate and the big reason this
happen happens is because we've
overemphasized as Society net worth net
worth is a number on a piece of paper
that could be converted into cash but
typically doesn't directly equate to
cash flow right so we've overemphasized
muscle like okay we're going to have
this we got this big net worth we got
bragging rights it's kind of like
revenue for a business revenue is
impressive it's awesome but ain't what
you make right it's what you keep right
so instead we're looking at cash flow
and those people that don't manage their
cash flow appropriately recessions
decimate them and the people that make
huge amounts of money are the ones that
have the cash to help create liquidity
for those people at a deep deep discount
that's called making money on the buy
well pausing in that for a second if if
we look at um saying okay keep a large
chunk of your assets in cash or cash
equivalent you know one side says well
you don't want to do that because with
inflation you know every day that cash
is worth less and less whereas if it's
in an asset and that asset happens to be
moving up then of course you're you're
not losing it but I guess there's an
offset saying by having that cash you
know the opportunities when they occur
and they always do occur at some point
the the return on those opportunities
because you're in cash are extraordinary
which is why you want to stay there
right and here's the thing we can all
have great opportunities come our way a
lot of people don't have the ability to
capitalize on that but recessions create
conditions for massive opportunities not
just an opportunity right and right now
we're in the longest period of time in
US history without a recession although
we're showing all the signs of the
recession and there's too many people
that are overextended overleveraged
utilizing credit and that's been
boosting the economy and as that cuts
back those people that have cash will
find the people in distress that were
only focused on net worth and can get a
40% return in the short term maybe they
missed out for two years maybe they
didn't earn any money during that time
but they're going to make up for it when
they come in and capitalize just like we
talked about in 2001 and 2002 so showing
up at the family office seem to be uh an
inflection point while you're taking
notes on your little red pad uh and
certainly LED you to some of these
conclusions what happened from there so
at that point it was actually an
interesting year because I would come
back to the firm that I was working for
and they'd bring in attorneys and
investment advisors and they'd pitch
these ideas and I was labeled a fanatic
because I just asked so many questions
and then they would say well but you
know because I'm I'm questioning how
they get compensated essentially right
and so it took me a minute but I had to
start my own thing let's talk about that
for a minute though you're questioning
how they're getting compens compensated
how are they getting compensated well
typically it's by commission or by fees
because of assets and management you
referred me someone once and uh I quoted
them for us to help him would be 20
grand MH and he said that seems really
expensive I said okay well it's all
relative because I've looked at your
portfolio and how'd you do last year he
goes well I lost money I said well did
you know that you paid $199,600 in fees
even though you lost money he said no I
said well see in the old days when you
were robbed someone showed up with a gun
on a horse or something now it's just
automatically coming out of the account
but I know how to look for those fees
and they said oh and by the way this was
someone who had 33 businesses so we
saved them $39,000 per month and going
through saving on tax restructuring
loans using the very four eyes that we
talked about and after that we became
friends because I said how do you how
expensive do you think we are and he
just giggle about it right like New
Yorker guy too by the way Boston yeah so
so
$39,000 a month just on savings which
what would it take to gener generate
that additional $39,000 a month and
trying to create new business well think
about it in today's world if we think
about investing MH like there's people
that are putting money in retirement
plans okay retirement plans follow a
faulty notion anyway because it's all
based upon an accumulation theory that
it's how much money you put in and so
that's the notion it takes money to make
money which a lot of people
unfortunately believe that that's not
true then it's what kind of return can
you get and most people believe that's
high risk equals High return so they're
taking a an unnecessary amount of risk
and then how long can you wait on the
time so money times times time so they
put money in these types of plans and
let's say that they do okay let's say
they do really well as a matter of fact
they get a million dollars in these
plans because there's not a lot of
retirement plans with a million dollars
Yahoo financ did an article saying it's
about 1.2% of people so that's not great
now let's look at today's interest rate
environments interest rates are so low
that's amazing for business owners it's
terrible for retirees because if your
interest rates are 3% you have a million
dollars but you're only getting $30,000
per year in interest that's all taxable
so you're a Millionaire on paper you're
a popper in life right and that's the
unfortunate thing here so if we're
trying to generate $39,000 per month
from a retirement plan think about the
amount of money that needs to be in
there we're talking about eight figures
eight figures of money and how are you
going to get there this guy was in his
50s it's going to take a long time it's
going to take really Savvy investing
because a standard mutual fund is not
going to get him there you ask all these
questions you find out about uh people's
fees and and you're starting to look at
it not from how can you get paid but
from the uh from the point of view of
the people you're trying to serve and
you decide you got to go out on your own
right and this is this is the difficult
piece of that because at that time I had
tasted what it's like to get paid
commissions it was pretty good yeah it's
pretty easy yeah right the transaction
happens like oh what do I pay you I'm
like oh the I get paid a commission and
you know it's like they don't even know
what what's leaving their hands right
and then I'm now going to okay we don't
get paid commissions we don't get fees
on assets under management you just have
to write us a check right that's a more
difficult stance yeah I think it's the
more ethical stance I think it's the
more valuable stance and as you know I
even put guarantees I'm like if we don't
find this money and put it back in your
life it's on us and we'll pay you back
and that's how you started your new
business that's how we started the
business and by the way the very first
spe I ever charged yeah was $1,500 I
remember the person looking at me like
that's so ridiculously low I don't trust
you right like I was like oh wait, 15500
per quarter you know like I H and threw
something out there but it was just it
was just so foreign and it was so like
it was difficult just and then all of a
sudden they started exponentially going
up on our side because our performance
of what we could provide for them went
up and we're like great let's look at
this as are you okay if I get paid 100
Grand if I save you $2 million and
people are like great and if they
weren't then they're just not in the
right mindset so you then went out
created your own firm you had some
Partners yep and three other partners
and then uh where did that go we did we
did really well I mean we did well
enough that we bought a company plane
and you know had all that kind of stuff
but in 2006 that company plane went down
with two of a minute wow so we we
started to host events and we created a
monthly membership this is before
WordPress and kajabi and all these
things that are basically free that you
could use as a platform we had to go
build something that cost us hundreds of
thousands of dollars to deliver content
on a daily basis because what we
discovered is no matter how much money
someone had or how much money we could
save them if they couldn't conquer the
scarcity mindset it didn't matter cuz
there's no greater destroyer of wealth
and I don't care how much luck someone
has how much discipline what kind of
rate of return they can get what
financial advisor they have if they're
in scarcity that fear doubt and worry
destroys wealth and they'll find a way
to mess it up so your premise and this
is important because we're talking about
wealth breakthroughs here right so your
premise is that mindset is the greatest
destroyer of wealth or can be right and
like I'll see people I'll put a video
out there and people say something like
yeah that's fine if you're wealthy and I
could never be that wealthy because of
either where they're born or their
circumstance but all it comes down to
their perspective our perspective
determines our action and so most
people's perspective is stuck in one of
two paradigms that are both scarcely
related one is playing not to lose
playing not to lose from the coal mining
town I came from is where you're holding
on to the Past you don't want any
Innovation you want fossil fuels and
coal to be the future because that's
your skill set that's what you know
that's where your paycheck comes from
and you'll hold on to that and grasp
onto that and people that only focus on
keeping the past the same are in the
most dangerous painful place moving
forward now there's other people that we
might even see on the cover of magazines
we might hear about getting Awards and
they're stuck in a different Paradigm
that's the play to win Paradigm and a
lot of people wear it like a badge like
I play to win and what they'll do is
they'll hustle their LifeWay they'll
lose family they'll lose friends and
they'll be aggressive right I play to
win I'm just going to put all the chips
on the table and then they get wiped out
and they have to start over and then
they get wiped out and they have to
start over and they get more bitter and
more exhausted and there's more body
bags laying around them as time goes on
because they're only thinking about the
future there's no celebration along the
way there is no acceptance and it's
almost like people that just never
healed from whatever trauma in their
life they're just going I got to fill
this void and if I'm successful enough
then maybe people will love me maybe
they'll accept me and you know you see a
lot of entrepreneurs in that situation
both are forms of scarcity both are
highly dangerous My Philosophy is Win
than play so what is what is when then
play and how might that apply to a
wealth breakthrough so when then play
begins with abundance right and look
Society helps to propagate scarcity
societies trained people to be busy and
consume it's the belief that if I work
hard enough I'll have what I want it's
the belief that one day someday I'll be
able to retire and finally get a live
life so it's always in the future right
it's always eventually or it's I'm just
never spending any money so I'll be okay
right it's one of those things and it's
kind of like I feel like Wall Street
went to Christmas Carol and they left at
intermission so they thought Scrooge
they thought that was a good deal like
oh look at him all of his money right
even though they missed the Redemption
story and that's kind of that Penny
Pincher until they get blisters on their
fingers and on the other hand you've got
the the notoriety of like o here's
someone that does so so much good in
society but they don't do good for
themselves or for their family or they
don't enjoy life so win then play is
that you actually create a game worth
winning you make sure that juice is
worth the squeeze and most importantly
you enjoy the journey along the way
because you're coming from abundance
abundance says hey even if there's a
fine amount of resources there's
Innovation there's human Ingenuity
there's creativity and in abundance we
believe that profit is evidence of value
creation and scarcity profit is evidence
of deception and coercion so people
don't want to be rich because they think
of rich people as bad or wrong or taking
something because in scarcity it's a
zero sum game one person wins at the
expense of another there's no
cooperation there's no communication
it's completely competition that they
try to decimate and Destroy people in
play not to lose are trying not to be
destroyed and people in play to win are
trying to destroy and when then play
it's you create a compelling exciting
future but you enjoy the journey along
the way and when it comes to money it
comes down to four things number one
make money on the buy you're not waiting
for 30 years you're looking at how you
can buy because of the situation that
your cash can buy a deep discount so
you're profitable from day one give me
an example of that in 2014 there was a
business that just skyrocketed coming
out of the recession but the problem was
the person leading the business was
teaching something that wasn't their
ultimate expertise and when they got
into some trouble or hit some bumps and
stumbled along the way they lost their
voice they lost their ability to deliver
the value they originally created and
they were willing to let it go but they
didn't want to lose their legacy I able
to come in and buy that at a deep
discount based upon that distress and so
right away I was profitable I just
interviewed a couple people that bought
businesses because the business owner
had had something happen with either
their health in one situation or with
their family in another situation and
they had to unload that so they could
focus on something because it was very
important to them to take care of those
things so they are willing to let that
go at a deep discount or real estate
there's people that they could go and
buy that piece of real estate because
they know what to do with it and the
person that owns it doesn't right maybe
they can go in and say hey if I
fractionalize this into 10 pieces and
sell this as a corporate retreat I can
sell it for 20% more MH but the person
selling it is going I can't rent this
thing out cuz I don't know how to rent
it so they're going to sell it for 30%
less you're already at 50% Improvement
simply because of your knowledge so you
win on the buy so basically saying don't
don't invest in something and wait some
time into the future but find a way to
win immediately on the transact right so
I just did this today okay okay today we
we want to create a new product that
helps people navigate the recession and
so rather than going and building it we
said why don't we pre-sell it mhm so we
sold 600 tickets to the virtual Summit
so we had 600 people registered and they
were now watching and then we filmed it
and let them know hey we're turning this
into a product so they paid for all the
production we tested out what was
working what wasn't working so we now
have 600 people going I want that and
now we'll have a product just two months
later that we can resell to the
marketplace and then they actually get a
so that's that's fascinating because
it's uh and I've heard this may be done
like uh on you know testing an
infomercial with a book but the book
isn't written yet if there's no interest
in in the book then they won't print the
book uh or if there were orders that
came in just refund the orders and you
don't have to get into it yeah I
pre-sold killing sacred cows 22,000
copies before it was ever released I
pre-sold it by saying hey I'll give you
this back then it was DVD and this
teleseminar series and these transcripts
and you'll get that right now but you
won't get the book tell it's complete so
they kind of knew what the content was
going to be in the book they could
benefit from it now with the bonuses but
now I already knew I was going to hit
New York Times I already knew there was
going to be momentum see erroneously in
play to win people go borrow money they
let venture capitalist into their life
that start to control all their actions
that minimize who they are with their
micromanagement and sometimes even push
that owner and founder out and change
the vision of the company or squash it
because it's not profitable enough even
if it's profitable right I would rather
see us go right to the customer and say
do you want this let's survey you help
us tell you tell us what you want and
then guess what we'll help build it but
you're going to pay us 50% of what it's
going to cost when it's done M you give
us feedback you become the case studies
and then you don't owe any money and
you've already got the momentum of
people utilizing it that's making money
on The Bu that's when then play we can
use it in business we can use it in real
estate and we can use it in investing if
we have knowledge too many people are
gambling and calling it investing
they're out there investing hoping that
it's going to work out hearing that
everybody else is doing it I got to get
in cryptocurrency oh I got to get in
this type of real estate but they don't
have the expertise so they don't know
when to exit they don't know if it's the
right time to buy you know and they'll
look and say well look Warren Buffett
makes a lot of money in the stock market
really Warren Buffett buys companies
he's got enough money that he buys the
company and employs his management
philosophy throughout that and all of a
sudden he has a degree of control over
the profitability versus someone who
just buys a share and I guess they can
have one meaningless vote but it doesn't
mean enough to influence that company so
he can make money on the buy maybe
because of a parallel company has that
that company can support and there's
that horizontal integration you know
we've got a friend Mike uh that he would
went and bought a company because he
knew how to list manage and all of a
sudden he turned that into profitability
from day one that's making money on the
buy all right so what's you said there's
four so make money on the buy what's the
next one second one is cash flow
investing we've been trained taught and
educated that everything's about
accumulation it's about Long Haul it's
about sacrifice it's about scrimping
saving you know delaying and deferring
instead of that look at cash flow from
day one how can you become a cash flow
investor that you get recurring Revenue
recurring Revenue can cover your
personal expenses because here's the
deal everybody's saving 10% of their
money if they're doing what they're
supposed to and then they try to earn
10% on that what ends up happening is
they don't earn 10% it's hard to save
the 10% and then they're not where they
want to be what if you have enough cash
flow coming in to cover your basic life
expenses either from assets like real
estate or or businesses or even your own
business and entrepreneurial income
inside of it that's the income that
comes in even if you don't show up so
I'm not talking about when you're in in
the mix of things I'm talking about when
there's scale and leverage there when
that covers the basic expenses 100% of
your active income can be reinvested you
have a 10 times advantage over anyone
else in that situation so if we start
shifting towards cash flow number one
we're alarmed when things don't work out
where if we're in accumulation we might
find out when it's too late that it's
not working out it's not on track there
isn't good enough pacing it's declining
so cash flow becomes that indicator the
third one is efficiency that was the
four eyes IRS interest Investments and
insurance it's plugging the leaks and
keeping more of what you make and then
the fourth one is actually that state
when you create economic independence
you've already won the game choose how
you want to play from there you're not
forced to make any decisions you don't
have to go to work to make the ends meet
or to pay the bills so you get to say
what is your life going to be about what
impact you want to make what's your
vision because remember I mentioned
activity and consumption is the
detriment for so many people in play to
win right they're not thinking about
Vision vision is when we break through
the norms and creation is the highest
form of reality and it's the highest
compensated thing out there vision is
the rarest commodity and to me vision is
when we talk about something so
compelling but it's outside of our reach
we don't have the bandwidth we don't
have the money maybe it's bring maybe
even a little bit of fear where we're
like I don't know how to accomplish it
but if it's inspiring enough to others
we now created a miraculous space where
people can come and support what we're
up to and when people can get beyond
their own capabilities that they can
enroll other people in the capabilities
and in bringing this forth that is where
real wealth is built that's the
Breakthrough wealth breakthrough is
Vision there's no greater way to earn
money than Vision because dollars follow
vision and vision is the most scalable
leverageable thing that exists in the
world when everybody else is trying to
borrow money to leverage may or may not
work for a lot of people but where the
ultimate Leverage is is in two forms our
mental Capital which is our ideas
knowledge wisdom tools strategies and
relationship Capital people networks
organizations you know individuals
customers and the bridge between those
is business so how do we take our mental
Capital to serve people and when we can
leverage that because we've created a
big enough picture that isn't just about
paying the bills that isn't just so
selfish it's only about us which
retirement is such a low barrier and a
low Mark the icons I've heard you say it
the IC never retire why because their
vision and purpose is big enough to
compel them forward until the day that
they die and they typically have the if
they take care of their health along the
way longevity right right so I really
look at Vision as the ultimate
breakthrough when we escape what society
says success is and when then play it's
when we've created a vision worthy of
our life when we've discovered our own
sole purpose our values our abilities
our passions and when we combine that
for something worthy of getting up for
every single day if that vision is
bigger than our problems we find away if
that vision is compelling enough other
people come and be part of it and that's
why the rich get richers cuz rich people
have vision and poor people have work
ethic so well and without a vision the
people perish you know as as the old
adage goes and I'm not yelling at you
man no I know you're just passionate I
know you're just EXC I get it it's the
Italian
side so one of the things that I think
Bears some investigation uh CU a lot of
times when we talk to people who are hey
you know you're doing a thing on wealth
and on wealth bre yeah you know they've
got this desire to be wealthy given your
experience how do you define wealth see
being rich means having money mhm but
being wealthy to me comes in five tracks
and in these tracks we're not looking
for balance because balance is
impossible people are out of balance all
the time when you're in flow you're out
of balance and flow is a great thing and
I think there's a lot of guilt and shame
when people are trying to be perfectly
balanced what we're looking for is depth
and Harmony and those five things it
begins with money money's part of our
wealth if you don't have money you
better be in a loin cloth out in the
woods with a bow and arrow otherwise
it's going to be a tough living right so
money is important and people that say
that it's not important usually don't
have much of it the second thing is
purpose if we spent the same amount of
time looking at our purpose on a daily
basis as we do managing our finances as
a society life would get exponentially
better because purpose drives money when
money is the beginning thing like I
remember going to school and it said in
my textbook the purpose of business is
profit mhm and I looked at it this way
the responsibility of business is profit
the purpose is why you're doing what
you're doing right and if your wise not
compelling enough profit won't see it
through during difficult times right so
purpose is so instrumental because
that's the vision that can help us reach
and that vision and purpose is the
container in which we live the actions
in which we take then the third one is
mindset because you got have all the
money in the world but if you have a
poor mindset you'll be afraid of losing
that money every day you'll destroy
relationships you'll lose sleep you'll
have stress you'll die early mindset is
essential it is part of wealth
absolutely then there's health health is
part of wealth if you don't have your
health you'd probably spend every last
dollar you had to get that Health back
there's that uh you know proverb that
says hey if you have your health you
could have thousands of dreams but if
you don't have it you're probably going
to have one right you're just trying to
get that back and there's a lot of
people that sacrificed their health in
the name of riches and then they end up
finding out that those riches slip
through the cracks just trying to get
their health back and then finally is
social so social wealth means relaxing
ation Recreation and Rejuvenation you
are your greatest asset not a stock not
a bond not some piece of real estate so
what are you doing to take care of
yourself and enjoy life along the way
and win then play we celebrate the wins
we consider quality of life money alone
is a misleading Benchmark because
there's always someone with more and no
matter how much you have you could live
in Zimbabwe where the it gets deflated
to nothing and it's not worth anything
the ultimate wealth is that you have
relationships that are rich that you
have experiences that you enjoy and that
you have quality of life so that you
actually can live a long period of time
so it's money it's purpose it's mindset
it's health and its social aspect that's
wealth and what I mean by depth and
Harmony depth is presence depth just
means it's not about quantity all the
times it's about quality it means that
you are present when you're in what
you're doing and then Harmony is that
you're deliberate and intentional about
what you do so there's times when I'm
writing a book I'm not in Balance I'm
writing you know I'm not seeing my
family as much but then I'm taking two
months and spending time in Italy later
on because I don't believe in retirement
I'm retiring along the way by having
experiences and I'm retiring that
concept because my purpose is greater
than just the selfish notion of me
living and not having to work anymore
right because I feel like I have more to
contribute to the world and I think
everyone does but the people that have
to retire like my dad that was a coal
miner retire from that but you
don't want to retire from something that
actually calls to who you are in that
Vision you know i' I've heard you
describe people you've worked with
before that are uh they have a lot of
money they're rich I guess in that
respect but they don't live wealthy
right what do you mean by that these are
the people that read you know they're
the broke millionaire they're the
miserable millionaire you wouldn't know
that they had the money because they've
never spent any of their money these are
people like when I flew to Vegas to
visit one of my friends he picked me up
and I think the hubcap rolled up and hit
someone at the uh you know he had such a
jalopy vehicle he's making a good
six-figure income but his car didn't
have air conditioning now this is what
that's like in Vegas in August the
windows are up and you're not sure if
it's a sauna so you're so hot so you
roll down the window then it's a blow
dryer which pain do you want right I'm
like thank God we're going to get to his
house soon when we got there he had it
set on his thermostat at 82 I was like
bro if I give you five bucks can we just
get that down in the 70s somewhere see
there's plenty of money that's being
compiled but if it's never utilized what
good is it and if it cripples a mindset
to only be thinking about what we can
save instead of how we produce
reductionist thinking actually helps us
to avoid wealth because no one shrinks
their way to wealth wealth is a game of
expansion it's a game of value creation
at the O at the core of it how do we
deliver value to others and if we can
deliver it to more people or we can more
deeply impact the people we serve the
more wealth we're going to have
especially if that's aligned with what I
would call our sole purpose or if that's
aligned with our vision and purpose so
you certainly Advocate uh living within
your means but people take that to
varying extremes maybe that you disagree
with so how would you define living
within your means my uh immature mind
early on in my life believe living
within my means was cutting things out
and eliminating like when I was first
getting married my father-in-law says if
you guys want to live in the basement
you're free to live there rent free so I
tell my wife I'm like hey we should move
in your parents basement she goes I
guess you don't care about having sex I
was like okay maybe we should have a
little bit better budget than that but
see you could save yourself into misery
right and that's kind of living within
your means is people think about cutting
and cutting isn't going to get you
wealthy right there's intelligent
cutting and then there's the mindset
that you only focus on that right so the
second thing is to be more efficient
within your means this is to plug the
leaks this is the four I IRS interest
Investments and insurance we want to
design that right but the last one is
the game changer and this will separate
everyone it's to expand your means when
I wrote five-day weekend I I had this
framework which is first off Let's help
you to make more money you got to be in
the right mindset to expand and grow and
make more money then second when you
make that money let's help you keep more
of the money that you make not by
budgeting but by intelligence then the
the third thing was now it's time to
grow your money see and when I was a kid
I wanted to grow the money before I did
anything else like I wanted to skip
these steps and make my money make money
even if it was only 700 bucks or $5,000
and then finally the fourth thing is you
got to invest back into yourself no
matter how far along you are you've got
to put your ego in check and be
infinitely curious curiosity is key for
wealth because if we feel we've arrived
at any time that's a dangerous place to
be we're at a faster more rapidly
changing world than ever in the next
seven years more of the S&P 500 will go
out of business in the last 70 that's
because small technology allows people
to do big things and you don't have to
have massive amounts of money or Capital
you just have to be able to create value
and we've seen that over and over
because even in the last decade we've
seen a lot of those companies didn't
make it so in that let's go to the
second piece of how to be more efficient
within your means so the first one is
the IRS and there's a framework to save
and look it doesn't matter which country
you live in I just like to keep it for
eyes or maybe now because we're talking
to the world here say it's uh to dot the
eyes and cross the t's right so then we
have three eyes in one t and that's tax
right and this framework Works no matter
where you are there's three parts to it
now there's two mistakes people make
around tax all the time and it destroys
wealth one is to defer tax deferring and
delaying tax is detrimental from a
standpoint of we don't I don't know
anyone that trusts the government do you
think they're going to lower taxes in
the future I mean they're addicted to
their consumption and the way that they
handle that consumption is either by
borrowing or by tax to cover what
they've borrowed so I think that with
the us being 23 trillion in debt I don't
really trust that they're going to lower
taxes in the future and if you defer
those taxes you have a few things
working against you one inflation
inflation means in the future you have
to have more money to buy the same
number of things that you buy today that
means you're going to be pushed into a
higher tax bracket because you have to
have more money right just to maintain
Lifestyle the second thing is because
the government's addiction to spending
they might have to raise taxes in the
future and if you have a financial
planner tell you be a lower tax PRACK in
the future because you don't need as
need as much money to live on they're
planning for you to fail you should run
yeah okay the second thing is and I see
this far too often people spend a dollar
to save 37 M I did this early on I
bought a car because you could do a
Section 179 which meant if it was over
5500 you got to write it all off in that
year that you bought it so it's cool I
can write that off I pay less in tax but
now I have a depreciating asset that I
didn't even want yeah saying you didn't
need the car right so I spent money I
didn't make money MH right that's like
someone going oh it's a 50% sale buying
something I didn't want or need right
yeah you just lost money on what you
bought if you didn't want or need it so
what to do instead is first thing is you
got to build the right team second thing
is you maximize your deductions and
third thing is the most powerful you
reclassify your income you got to have
the team and this is the hardest thing
even though it's the easiest thing to
understand you just got to have data
whether you're using an app to get your
data or whether you hire a bookkeeper a
CFO or you know a controller timely data
is essential if you get your data to
your account after the year's over you
overpaid on your taxes so you've got to
meet at least quarterly with your team
you got to have the right data to have
the meeting and the other two people on
the team are going to be a tax
strategist and an attorney most people
miss the attorney and that's where the
biggest tax advantages are a tax
strategist might be a CPA in America but
it might not be some CPAs are more
historians telling you what you owe
based upon what you earned not how you
navigate the tax system because sure we
have a few hundred pages of why we have
to pay taxes but then we have thousands
of pages of why we don't if you know how
to navigate it properly so this is the
three people you got the controller
you've got the tax strategist and then
you've got the attorney and if you own
commercial property you add an engineer
an engineer can do something called a
cost segregation study that anyone that
owns commercial property which is
greater than a fourplex or a commercial
building they can get accelerated
depreciation one of the reasons why
Trump pays so little on taxes is because
of that feature right there so now you
want to meet with these people every
quarter M and your job is to think
outside the the box to be a brainstorm
and their job is to think inside the box
and what the rules and regulations are
when I have these meetings I go hey I
just bought a sidebyside Canam right
these are like you've seen it the
turbocharged golf carts going 100 miles
hour on the dirt roads they're the price
of a car right so I start the meeting by
saying can I write that off and they say
no and I go wait it's in the intro to my
speaker video because I just filmed me
and my family in it everyone that comes
and does my podcast will be able to
write in it here's the liability waiver
showing that they can write in that it's
going to be in other videos including
the on outro to the podcast and by the
end of the conversation we're going to
write 50% of that thing off and this is
what's fascinating because I I think
what you're saying I I agree with it is
that people overd delegate to these
so-called experts and they're more
Monday morning quarterbacks than
quarterbacks right right yeah they're
looking backwards rather than saying we
got to go score some points wealth is
built in proactivity M it's easy for all
of us to be reactive retroactive or
reactive it's easy yeah but the people
that are proactive are The Visionaries
the people that are proactive have the
riches the people that just are busy and
active and consuming they get spoiled
you know but and this is a great example
where you walked in and said oh can I
write this off and they're like No And
and most people I'm going to say 98 out
of 100 times are probably going to say
okay what's what's the next item on the
agenda as compared to you saying wait a
minute what if not so fast what and not
your friend what if what if in what
cases could it be written off would
there be any situation where any
organization could write this off right
and then I'll go into I'm going to Italy
I'd like to write that off and then they
laugh and I go well I think I needed my
annual corporate compliance meetings and
like oh yeah I think better with wine in
Italy than I do in my home in Utah and
then they laugh but then by the end of
that I think it was 55% of that trip I
got it right off I filmed while I was
out there I got footage of where my
great-grandfather was from I mean we did
certain things to help justify that so
you want to have these quarterly
meetings and then every 3 years you want
to look back and see if you missed
anything so going back maybe people have
missed research development they've
developed something on the Internet
they've built an app they've improved a
software system they can get credits for
that for in the United States for
example or I had to have research to
write my books and that research allowed
me to get domestic production credits of
$28,000 one year 31,000 another year
32,000 I was able to go back that's
money that I had overpaid so every three
years a different set of eyes every
quarter I have the meeting it's a 20
minute to an hour meeting depending on
how many items and here's how I run that
meeting the second column here we're
talking about is deductions so
deductions I just have two rules number
one I say does this expense relate to my
business and so this is now assuming
people want to build wealth and even if
it's a side business a business is a
huge Advantage right 83% of people that
have side businesses want to make it a
full-time gig we're moving into that
type of an economy and 70% of people in
America have a side business but most of
those are not set up to maximize tax
savings that'll be the reclassification
strategy here in a minute but all I do
is I go could this relate to my business
and if I'm uncertain I just document it
for that quarterly meeting right and if
it does then I make sure to get it
reimbursed by the business but I charge
it to a personal credit card that way if
I don't end up using it it's not
infringing upon my corporate bail what
this means is if you're a corporation
and you accidentally spend money out of
the corporation on personal things you
don't have the liability protection you
thought you had so even if if when it
comes and you allocating and you uh say
okay I the company paid for this but
then I took it as a distribution after
the fact that would help but it might
not always hold up I like it as clear as
possible but that would at least be an
argument okay they're going to what
they're going to do is if you ever Su
they're going to call that an alter ego
Alter Ego this isn't really a business
this is just you know Patrick or this is
just Garrett so so I like to just charge
it then I write it down then I have
those statements in front of me and then
when I we have the meeting I go I bought
this I bought this what can I write off
and then we go through some of it's a
percentage we can write off sometimes I
get a flat out no but every now and
again I get a flat out no and I go what
type of companies could write this off
and my favorite was I like to buy nice
clothes sometimes and uh I'd like to
write those off but the uniform code
says if I can wear them out there every
day it's not really a write off I said
but guys Hollywood's buying normal
clothes for their actors all the time
are you telling me they don't write it
off they're like well they're a
production company I said oh so if I had
a production company which I have a TV
studio I have a podcasting Studio I have
clothes that stay there pretty much all
the time could I write that off and like
well if it's a production company yes
see I'm here to brainstorm and challenge
they're here to keep me within the laws
right on that call I could be as wild
and crazy as I want because we're not
filing anything right okay and there's
so many rules out there that people miss
the Augusta rule where I can rent my
house out for 14 days I get to rent that
to my business if I want write it off in
the business but I don't have to claim
it as personal income or I could pay my
kids I can pay my kids up to $112,000
that's tax deductible to the business
taxfree to them even though I control
the account slow down for the people who
are writing okay so let's get back to
this Augusta rule yeah I want to make
sure I heard you correctly you're saying
you could rent your house to your
business for 14 days and you don't have
to take it as income right so the
Augusta rule is the nickname for and the
way it came about is there was a Senator
out of Georgia who happened to own a
home in Augusta M now that was his
second home MH so there was 14 days a
year he could rent that out for a lot
more than any other time of year that's
during the Masters right so he wanted to
rent it out but he was frustrated he had
to pay tax on that so he just slipped
that into one of the bills and now that
tax codee got changed that you can run
out your home and that doesn't to be to
your business it could be to anyone you
could Airbnb it for 14 days you don't
have to claim it as income right right
so it's just taxfree money or you get to
write it off for the business and get it
take it as a personal income taxfree 14
days or less that's what I'm saying so
the business can expense it but you can
take it personally you pay well yeah and
uh I have to imagine there's some
parameters around how much you can rent
it for you you know but but as long as
you're in line with what might be
considered a market rent in that case if
you're if it's during the Master's golf
tournament you can that's the beauty
yeah is the parameters are are dictated
by the Demand right so when the Super
Bowl was in Atlanta I had a bunch of
clients in Atlanta I called them all and
I said this is the time to host
something at your house go on Airbnb see
how much homes similar to that are
renting for and they were like oh my
gosh it's astronomical Sundance yeah in
Park City which is how much bigger rent
is it during Sundance it's it's Astron
as a matter of fact like tenfold right
at least some companies will come into
town and rent people's stores and pay
their whole year's rent for the two
weeks right so we're looking for those
unique opportunities at the time that we
do it it's all in documentation
documentation is your friend and I know
there's going to be people that listen
to this and they go all this is sounds
risky right I'm here to tell you that
I've been doing this for over 20 years
now and we haven't had audit issues
because this is all legal and ethical
things and part of what I'm giving is
very us-centric but here's the deal I've
had people in Canada that have heard
this platform that saved $100,000 this
guy Yuri because he's using the
framework it's a little bit different
with the nuances whether you're in
Australia or the UK but you can use
having a team meeting with them every
quarter asking them these kind of
questions that's how you're going to
navigate the whole thing how much can
you pay your kids a year 12,000 a year
if you're in the US so you can pay them
12 Grand a year they don't have to pay
tax on it right yeah and here's how you
navigate that properly you better have
them do $12,000 worth of work okay so
early on I missed these deductions
because I didn't really know what could
I justify these young kids of mine to do
um I didn't realize I it had a model by
putting on my website and that's $2,500
a piece per year I missed that M but
that's a union standard right now I'm
like well how much do I pay an MC at an
event what if I have my son introduce me
before I went on stage so I brought him
out he's 9 years old introduces me to a
thousand people he's fired up and stoked
the crowd's fired up and stoked then he
signed books with me for 5 and a half
hours afterwards wow now he didn't sign
nearly as many books as me because he
tried to write and it take forever but
he was fascinated it was cool because
the what would the rock fers do it's a
legacy book and there's my son right or
I had to take a Redeye once to speak in
Boston so I brought the kids cuz I
didn't want to torture my team with it
and they're handing out books and
they're there with me those are higher
you know dollar things than if I have Mo
a lawn or if I have them file something
so you've got to document what they did
you can't just pay it with no
documentation because some people are
going to be afraid like well am I going
to get in trouble with IRS this is legal
and ethical strategies absolutely not
going to get in trouble with the IRS
Amendment the IRS is going to say yes or
no whether or not they approve that
Amendment based upon what you send them
so you've got to have the right tax team
so what's the next thing we should
consider well reclassification is the
game changer so some people do a good
job maximizing their deductions almost
no one does good with reclassification
there's four ways to reclassify one you
take active income and reclassify it to
passive income for tax purposes I'll
give some examples two you take ordinary
income and make it a capital gain
capital gain could be 0% 15% or 20% and
the top tax bracket in the US is 37 a
half so you can see the savings there
number three tax-free income which is
almost exclusive to capital gain assets
like a business or a piece of real
estate or a highly appreciated stock and
then tax Arbitrage now tax Arbitrage
sounds complicated but it's this simple
if I spend a dollar on something I
better get more than a dollar back from
the government no more dollar for 37
it's a dollar for $2 okay so let me give
just an example or two in each area
active to passive you can set up a
corporation you can pay yourself a
reasonable salary if you have employees
what is the test in your industry you
know I know you you have a background of
being a chiropractor and we look at the
reasonable salary for a chiropractor
versus what Patrick gentempo the
chiropractor would get two very
different numbers but as long as you're
in the reasonable salary test you pay
the rest in distributions distributions
avoid self-employment tax which is as
high as 15.3% right so you're just
paying yourself two checks instead of
one right or let's say that you own a
building and you could actually rent
that building out to your business
charge yourself the highest possible
rent based upon the comparables and
that's going to get you a passive income
at $10.99 instead of W2 that's going to
save you that money as well so ordinary
income to capital gains let's say you do
business internationally you do right
you guys do business internationally you
could actually run that business of
anyone that buys these documentaries
outside the United States through an
international sales company and anything
that flows through that company is
capital gains so you've just reduced
your taxation to capital gains it's
automatic capital gains M how did I not
know that well I wanted you to interview
me so if I keep giving you an Insight
every time you interview me I keep being
in everything that you do so that's my
secret sauce there um taxfree there's
several ways like just to give a more
obscure one but that's completely
taxfree is called a 122 A 122 says if
you have a C corporation that's at least
5 years old but was started after like
1983 you could sell up to $10 million
taxfree on a business and tax advantaged
above 10 million so I've only seen that
happen once but it's worth knowing about
if you have a business that could fit
that category there's other things like
a caps trust which allows you to spread
your taxes out after over 10 years or up
to 20 years there's something called a
charitable trust where you can actually
donate your business to a charitable
organization when the business sells it
funds A trust that you get to be the
first beneficiary of the charity keeps
whatever's left over when you die which
is estimated to be 10% so you give the
charity 10% rather than the government
20 and by the way you get a tax
deduction for what they think you're
going to leave behind at the charity so
not only do you not pay tax upon the
sale tax break that could be a 50% swing
for people right so there's there that's
a few taxfree examples in tax Arbitrage
I'll just give two examples one I bought
some artwork you've seen the artwork
before um I bought a big collection at a
deep discount because I agreed to never
sell it on the open market and after 3
years I started to donate it when you
donate after 3 years it moves from Book
value to appraised value and those
museums get it appraised when I donate
it and I get a deduction for the full
appraised value so I spent 300 Grand I
got 2.2 million in tax deductions wow so
I got paid to own art and then another
thing is a conservation ement let's say
you know we have a mutual friend that
had a lot of land uh out there in
Colorado close to floron right and I'm
like hey you have all this land are you
ever going to develop it he said no but
he had 31 acre lots right and then a
bunch of other Acres I said if you do a
conservation eement saying you're never
going to develop it you get that tax
advantage over a century right now today
and so all of a sudden you can get major
tax advantage in some cases depending on
the development rights could be worth as
much as what you paid for the property
wow people in Florida that own property
where these Turtles that you know dig
and everything if they give that up in a
conservation eement because of the
preservation of an endangered species it
could be a high high value or someone in
West Texas
owning land that they have a hard time
selling but has a lot of sand that could
be used for fracking you get it
appraised as if you were to develop it
for fracking and you might get a six and
a half or 7 to1 tax deduction so all of
a sudden you're getting paid for the
land in tax benefit rather than trying
to sell it to someone that may it's not
developed yet so those are just a couple
tax Arbitrage examples so look I know
that this is a lot of information in a
short period of time but this is the
bottom line three by3 by3 by3 the three
columns you want to have a team three
people on that team right you got the
controller or bookkeeper that could be
someone very part-time you've got the
tax strategist you've got the tax
attorney which is mostly
reclassification The Tax Strategies is
mostly deduction the second column is
deduction the third column is
reclassification look back every three
years see if you miss something meet
with them every single quarter ask
compelling questions and the hardest
part of this is finding the team if you
find the team the team the game is one
and win then play the game is one a lot
of times when you pick the teams right
you pick the right Financial team you've
already won because they can help you
navigate like that family office like I
saw when I was 22 years old man they
have major major massive advantages
because of what they could do that no
one else gets a chance to do well so
let's say now that uh I'm earlier on
yeah um I'm working but I've saved 30
grand yep and I I want to have a wealth
breakthrough I want to I want to start
moving toward uh building Financial
Freedom in my life what would you
recommend so the first thing I recommend
is you got to set up a separate account
could be a checking savings or money
market but we need a more elegant
tracking system what I find people have
insatiable appetites when money's
sitting around and businesses have an
even more insatiable appetite and
finding excuses to spend the money so
the separate account is a wealth capture
account it's a place where you're saying
this is my money that I'm going to
automatically save but then deliberately
invest and your first Benchmark in that
is you want to have at least three
months set aside for personal expenses
that way if you have a health issue a
family issue a financial surprise which
we all are going to have those sometimes
you've got more staying power right from
there I would look into cash flow
banking now cash flow banking is a
Rockefeller method of how they've
perpetuated wealth my belief is why not
buy net worth and build cash flow most
people only focus on building net worth
and neglect cash flow right so how do we
do that this is very interesting because
this is something that happened in the
1950s with GE GE decided they wanted to
recruit the very best talent in the
world but to recruit that Talent they
said how do we do that so that we could
be number one or number two in every
category we're in so what they decided
is we got to go recruit these Executives
that already have a job and offering
them something their current
organization can't so they went and they
recruited them and said we'll give you a
pension now the way they funded the
pension was the right way initially they
didn't use the stock market they bought
Life Insurance corporate owned life
insurance and here's what would happen
that would build cash value that cash
value would supplement the pension after
the person retired and the person would
die the death benefit would come back
tax-free to the corporation and give
them between six and 7% taxfree after
expenses right this got so big that
Walmart got in trouble because they even
buying it on their greeters you know and
be like hey you just profited from
Grandpa's debt so what you know kind of
got some some negative press but but
ultimately we can do this as individuals
we could buy cash value policy but
you've got to design it right you've got
to design it how the Rockefellers would
design it or you know really wealthy
families which is very cash-heavy so
rather than getting 1% on your savings
account or 2% if you're in an internet
Bank what the banks do is they can take
a third of their reserves and put it
into cash value policies now these are
cash heavy very very cash heavy from day
one that they can pull the money back
out but it doesn't get hit with tax it's
protected from liability and bankruptcy
right it's available and accessible
within 30 days of when it's first
deposited and they can usually get it
within 72 hours upon request right and
if the market goes down it does not go
down so rather than getting 1 to 2%
you're getting four or 5% tax advantaged
so now you've got a place to store this
cash that you can then capitalize when
other opportunities come along and
that's where you got to be patient and
discover your investor DNA where can you
invest where you have unique Insight
unique knowledge and unique ability and
then you look for making money on the
buy or if you own a business it might be
putting money into the business to
increase profits might be hiring someone
it might be putting a piece of equipment
into place it might be your own personal
education but the place that you never
get to stop investing is into yourself
and into your knowledge into your
network and into your mentors that makes
the biggest difference because we all
face scarcity at sometimes we all face
cash crunches we all face changing
economies and we don't want scarcity
thinking to ever take over and make high
emotion create poor financial decisions
right so you want that outside
perspective and then from there I think
investor DNA is where we really discover
our core competencies our core values
our core drivers so that we're
interested in it and then we focus
instead of diversify diversification is
admission of ignorance I don't know it's
going to work let me spread myself thin
diversification is a play not to lose
strategy that if you're really affluent
makes sense because you have more money
than you can allocate to the things that
you know maybe right so it's more of a
stability thing but as a growth strategy
it's a horrifically bad choice
especially if it's a lot of you're
spreading yourself thin and things you
don't know you're playing defense right
Andrew Carnegie said he put all of his
eggs in one basket and watch it like a
hawk and so if you build your foundation
you have your liquidity you have your
cash flow bank now you your permission
to capitalize on the right opportunities
so for me there's only a few places I
invest I invest into my businesses which
I have three businesses that I look to
expand I like it because it's
threedimensional number one the more
cash flow that can come in without my
involvement the more Equity I create and
actually get to hear from the people
that I serve I get hugs sometimes I get
gifts my mutual fund never gave me that
I gave me a piece of paper in the mail
to tell me why I just lost money so so
that's a very different thing or
business acquisition when the economy
turns that's for me for other people
that investment might be real estate but
only if you know real estate and you're
not going to know everything if you're
just getting started is it going to be
Fix and Flip for you is it going to be
you know cash flow real estate on
rentals is it going to be commercial get
really really good at one thing and look
to make money on the
Grand might not be a ton of money but it
can get you started invest in your
Education First in your infrastructure
second and then third capitalize on
opportunities when they arise but don't
go prematurely allocate it right so is
there a level of patience here so if
absolutely we got the $30,000 like I got
to go do something with it as compared
to saying let me educate myself really
well about something before I start
jumping into it if you want to be
wealthy yeah wealth requires that
patience it doesn't mean we sit around
and wait for things to happen to us it
means we invest in our knowledge so
we're prepared when the opportunity
comes so let's say that okay take that
the next level I get that I don't know
what I might have passion about yet I I
want to survey the landscape a little
bit and maybe something will start to to
you know uh pop out to me saying oh you
know what that that really captures my
interest right is there how would you
recommend starting down a path saying I
want to see maybe where I have
competency or what I might have
passionate around if I don't know what
that is right now look courses help
right what they're watching here with
weal breakthroughs hell because you get
exposed to a lot of things right in my
book 5day weekend we wrote about a ton
of different types of Investments most
of which I would never touch because
they would bore me right see early on I
wanted to make more money as an investor
than an educator so I had over 100 real
estate properties at one time and you
know what I didn't like it I didn't like
deferred maintenance issues I didn't
like dealing with property managers I
didn't like dealing with financing in
Banks and so it was more drudgery it was
supposed to be passive income but it was
very active so I said why am I in real
estate and real real property when I can
be an intellectual property I like
creating content I like writing books I
like being on video I love interviewing
I love being interviewed this is
something I'm passionate about and I
didn't discover that early on I
discovered that more in like 2007 right
so I had almost nine years of being an
investor and I invested in two IPOs I
invested in a hard money lending fund
that I started and initiated with two
other partners which was a nightmare the
amount of work and all these things
dered and distracted me because I
thought based upon the books I had read
that real estate was the only place to
put your money and for the right person
if you're going to treat it like a
business it can be a good place to put
your money but for 70% of people out
there they're just starting it's
horrific place to put your money because
you're not ready you don't understand
you don't know so you've got to invest
in that education you've got to be
exposed to things and see if you really
are intrigued if you're interested what
are you reading about like we've got
people because of you that are so
intelligent in health they invest in
health related companies right you know
I invest in financial and intellectual
property related companies so you know
that's really the places to look but
first plug the leaks and probably the
first place to invest is in the team
because you've got to have The Advocates
people that do due diligence people that
save you a bunch of cash and people that
got your back to tell you when you're
not thinking straight because I've put
on rose-colored glasses before I'm I'm
ready to make that investment I'm trying
to do due diligence but I'm just looking
for all the evidence that confirms my
bias right where when I have other
people like norm and Ryan and Andrew who
are my due diligence team they don't
have that same attachment and they can
prevent me from making those missteps
mistakes or at least making sure I have
better collateral that I have better
protection or that I'm negotiating at a
different level well as always Garrett
it feels like we're just getting started
but uh boy that's a lot of great
information really appreciate you uh
coming and sharing it and I know that uh
this is some this this segment is
something that's probably going to be
watched a few times a lot of takeaway
value so I appreciate you not showing up
with fluff but showing up with some some
real value that people can put to work
so thank you thanks for the work you're
doing and appreciate the friendship
thank
you
hi and welcome to your episode 4 bonus
interview you wouldn't want to miss this
one Marco centelli is the founder and
CEO of Nado real estate Investments and
a well-known podcaster in this bonus
interview he's going to show you how 90%
of millionaires created more wealth
through real estate than any other
investment he also has a two-step wealth
building blueprint you can use to build
endless streams of active income even
better what Marco's going to show you
can work for anyone regardless of how
old you are or where you are in life
settle in for a good one here's
[Music]
Marco Marco thanks for taking some time
with us today thank you Patrick glad to
be here so you're you're a big fan of
real estate investing so how did that
come about what what got you into real
estate well I don't know how but at a a
very early age I just knew I wanted to
be wealthy and this probably happened
when I was in the range of 8 to 10 years
old so I made it my mission at the time
to study wealth business money whatever
it could be and I just became an
entrepreneur at an early age in fact I
was coding at the age of 13 I couldn't
buy real estate but I was studying real
estate in my teens when I turned turned
18 I bought my first rental property it
was a town home unit I bought it fixed
it up I leased it I managed it myself
held it for a number of years the
biggest mistake I made at the time not
knowing it at the time is I sold that
property but that's when the writing was
on the wall and I just continued going
down that direction I got my license
continued to buy real estate and learned
as I went did you go to college or you
went right into business I went to
University and interestingly enough I
took criminology huh had nothing to do
with business but I thought that law
enforcement was what I wanted to do but
I realized that number one it wasn't my
passion number two I couldn't make the
type of income to create the wealth and
sustain the wealth that I wanted uh so I
shifted gears and I became an
entrepreneur started some businesses and
invested in real estate and has it
pretty much been real estate from day
one for you or any other businesses that
you were in the short answer to that is
I've had multiple businesses and
therefore multiple failures and
experiences the best teacher so when you
can fail fail fast and fail forward you
build on your past experience and
success to do better and create more the
next time you move forward um that
happened with real estate but it also
helped with business but I I combined
all that experience together to help me
uh not only invest in real estate
personally as investment but to create a
business wrapped around real estate
investing so now I can show other people
and teach other people what I was doing
uh happily and that's what I'm
ultimately passionate about when you
were young in in self-studying were
there any particular influences that
stand out early on it was Tony Robbins I
still have to this day the personal
power program on audio cassette with the
journal right I you know I have my
values my goals written in that um but
he was an influence uh Brian Tracy was
an influence I don't think I had a lot
of mentors early on in in the real
estate space I just knew from
conversations with other people that
real estate has been and always was the
true wealth Creator I mean wealth is
held
in real estate but if you know the right
strategies you can create and build
wealth rapidly using real estate so not
only did I come to learn quickly at an
early age that real estate was a wealth
Creator but it was a way to create
enough passive income that you can
become financially free and knowing that
as a teenager I decided to pursue that
and build as much income as I possibly
could to funnel into investment real
estate because if you can do that if you
can figure that part out the key to
creating wealth is actually to learn how
to create as much active income as you
can and convert that into passive income
because the more passive income you have
the faster you will Achieve Financial
Freedom so the key to going from active
or earned income to passive and
portfolio income is really the key to to
creating Financial wealth so do you make
like a distinction between income and
wealth or or you know uh you know being
rich say because you're a high earner
versus having true wealth or are they
kind of the same thing to you
they're related but there's a
distinction so when we talk about wealth
let's differentiate wealth in being rich
okay okay so someone who is truly
wealthy financially speaking will always
be
wealthy why because we're talking about
streams of income you have passive
income it's predictable it's sustainable
and it's passive someone who's rich
might look good on the surface they may
have may have a lot of possessions they
may have a lot of money in the bank but
the reality is is that we're talking
about chunks of cash so if you burn
through it if you have a million dollars
and you're living off $100,000 a year
you can sustain yourself for 10 years
but then what happens at that point
you're broke the wealthy person now has
passive income that's sustainable and
predictable every single month every
single year that they can survive
forever and not only that pass it on to
their heirs so when you're truly wealthy
you have the ability to sustain and and
and hold your your wealth and your
lifestyle and and more so whatever you
want to do you have the freedom not only
it's Financial Freedom but time Freedom
you have that you don't have that if
you're rich so the income from being
wealthy comes from the passive income
that you have from your assets the
assets that you build to create that
passive income um like the real estate
that I was buying the reason I bought
the real estate was to create the wealth
through Equity that I can now turn into
more real estate that kicks off a steady
stream of passive income so now I have
the passive income to to create the
Financial Freedom I need yet keeping the
equity at the same time that's true
wealth did anybody in your family that
your parents or other people uh were
they like have the type of personality
you did toward you know wealth creation
or or having wealth breakthroughs or was
it a different upbringing for you I
wasn't born with a silver spoon in my
mouth uh both my parents worked
sometimes two jobs uh I I I did not come
from wealth uh in fact my parents were
immigrants from Italy so uh my mother
worked two jobs for the longest time to
make against meat my father was
extremely conservative he did not want
to buy a house he he did not want to
invest in a business my mother was
completely the opposite she was
entrepreneurial and my father held her
back but recognizing that I got a taste
of both uh mindsets but I chose my own
path I just knew again early on that I
did not want to work 9 to5 I did not
want a j o which some people refer to is
just over broke you know the reality is
is that about 60% of the US population
doesn't have a financial plan 47% can't
even put $500 together in the case of an
emergency 50% of the US population
doesn't even have $500 in savings it's a
pretty scary thing that doesn't
necessarily mean that real estate
investing is not attainable for most
people I'll never say it's attainable
for everybody because it's just not
right for everybody but I never came
from you know an environment of of
wealth or riches or or even education
for that matter you know I went to
public school and uh but I found my own
way I just identified with it and your
first generation here then yes wow so
that's uh that's quite a you know
American Dream success story in a sense
you know parents have son of immigrants
that finds his own way so what are most
of your business activities now I
actually have uh my finger in five
businesses the core business is the real
estate investment business where we
freely provide knowledge education
resources uh to Real Estate Investors or
want to be Real Estate Investors I just
call them people um and ultimately it's
not about the education it's actually
about taking action and building a real
estate portfolio so now you have that
passive income and you are creating
wealth so once you have the education
and you're you have the willingness and
the ability to invest we have properties
in 22 different markets around the
country at any given time they're
completely TurnKey ready tenant occupied
professionally managed so you do like a
vetting process uh for people ahead of
time that want to invest in real estate
yeah it's a it's a system that created I
to give you the history of the system
really it it happened back in late 2003
when Real Estate was on fire um you know
markets were preting all around the
country uh I chose to get back into real
estate investing but full-time because I
just come out of a.com crash at the time
I was uh the third co-founder of a dotc
business painful very painful you know
it's one of those rag the richest
stories where you think you're going to
be a multi-millionaire overnight and we
were on that path but when the NASDAQ
crashed all the Venture Capital funding
dried up and um you know we had to close
the business we had to shut it down and
I had to lay off 105 people how so with
that how important is it for people
understand that because we could sit
here have a conversation talk about all
the wealth you built in real estate how
you advise other people to do it Etc and
boy isn't this great but maybe what
people don't hear are the times where uh
you know the dark night of the Soul you
know you think you're going to be a
millionaire there's a dotom so how do
you overcome that psychologically and
keep going to to rebuild and and to find
new ground to stand on to be able to
create wealth you really need to be
clear about what you're trying to
achieve you need to have a purpose you
need to know what you want and you need
to have written goals I know you hear
this time and time and time again the
reality is a small percentage of people
actually sit down think about what they
want and write down their goals it's not
a hard exercise but there's something
about doing that that puts in motion the
things that you need to do in order to
get on the path to gain the knowledge
you need in order to get to that next
level build the team and start executing
on whatever your plan is so this is this
is kind of important because especially
coming from you said some of the
influences like Tony Robbins or Brian
Tracy who were all about goal setting
right and and you know documenting what
it is you you want to make happen so you
talk about you know hey it's not that
hard and is this is why it's important
what do you think the psychology of
someone who says I have ambition but
they won't get to a point where they'll
start writing down goals what are they
telling themselves or what what do you
think that means what what's how do you
interpret that if they don't have the
ambition they probably don't have clear
enough goals um and or they don't have a
burning desire they really don't want it
bad enough because we all have the same
amount of time MH we choose to do what
we do in that time mhm and so whatever
is driving you to do what you do is
where you put your priority if you're
watching TV every night for 3 hours
clearly that you know you're either
really lazy or you don't have clear
specific measurable attainable goals
that excite you that fire you up that
make you want to do something better for
yourself for your family for your your
legacy your heirs uh but when you can
create that passion you will take action
you will do what it takes you will build
a team around you to execute on plans
that you build it's not that hard people
just hold themselves back through fear
they talk themselves out of what they
could do look to get results you need
three things you need the ability the
willingness and the execution if you
have those three things you can achieve
almost anything that makes perfect sense
so let me ask this in your perspective
what aspect or what ratio would you say
of your success personally and and maybe
we could extrapolate this as a general
rule is your headp space and what ratio
of the outcome is you choosing real
estate as the vehicle like you know so
because some people say oh it's well
real estate's just a great investment
and I heard you say sort well not for
everybody it's for maybe for a lot of
people and it certainly is for you but
how much of it is the you know if
somebody's trying to have a wealth
breakthrough right now they're trying to
say I want to I just want to get on a
path and and and break through and
become wealthy so some might say well
real estate is the path could be true
but how much of that is their headp
space 90% wow okay so I wasn't expecting
that answer the reason it's 90% is
because everything starts ends and lives
in your head MH what you do what you
achieve and what you don't do and what
you don't achieve all starts from your
mindset you know the Great Book Think
and Grow Rich Napoleon Hill talks about
this extensively that's why that book is
worth reading at least once a year I'm
part of five masterminds I was part of
seven it's very timec consuming but I
want to surround myself with like-minded
people and inally i' say the investment
in these masterminds is not small right
I mean some of them are as much as
$25,000 a year or so I I have friends uh
that have $100,000 masterminds I have
three friends that have $100,000
masterminds I'm not in those ones but I
am in the 25 $335,000 masterminds why do
I do that because I want to surround
myself with like-minded people who are
achieving who are goal oriented
achieving the same types of things I
want to achieve or maybe not but they're
all trying to better themselves they
believe in personal development they
believe in growth they want to better
themselves and achieve more so I go
there to learn to grow personally inside
and outside it's not just the
information I get from The Mastermind
but it's the networking and the growth
that I get from it but mindset is so
critically important you have to first
of all believe that you can achieve what
you want to achieve and if you don't
feel that way follow my first rule of my
10 rules for successful real estate
investing and that is educate yourself
if you just sit down for a couple of
hours a week and read a book and just
set a goal to finish a book every week
or two on real estate on anything
personal development from Brian Tracy
Tony Robbins whatever it may be awaken
the giant within whatever it is you will
start to believe that you can achieve
more than what you're actually doing
because your limiting factor typically
is either you and if it's not you it's
the five friends that you hang around
with the most because if you average out
their income it's probably going to be
what you're ultimately going to earn and
make so if you are broke find five new
friends who weren't so if if I were to
ask you um okay uh I'm want to get
started on this path I want to read a
real estate book or real estate
investment book what's the first thing
that pops into your head well
fundamentally it's it's Rich Dad Poor
Dad you know and the reason I say that
not that it's a tactical book that's
going to give you the the howtos I mean
we teach the howto
but getting into a space where you get
out of the Matrix to use that analogy of
you know the movie where you understand
what assets are what cash flow really
means what income producing assets are
for and the difference between
consumerism and investing and all that
stuff you know you really need to start
there and then build upon that so the
entire richdad book series is a great
place to start Gary Keller's book uh
millionaire real estate investor is
another great book this is going to give
you a lot of the mindset and it's going
to give you a lot of the strategy that
you need M there's still more to be
learned in terms of the tactics but then
that's gets to the question of am I an
active real estate investor or am I a
passive real estate investor which are
you well I'm both but that's because I
I'm a full-time real estate investor and
I have the time and the the knowledge
and the ability to do it but if someone
came to me and said what should I be I
would say look stop watching you know TV
and all these you know flipping shows
because that really is not real estate
investing by my definition uh when
you're fixing and flipping properties
you're making again chunks of cash it's
transactional it only lives for as long
as you're actually doing the active um
job of buying distressed properties
fixing them up and flipping them
assuming you're making money at it
because you can lose a lot of money just
as easily as you can make money but a
lot of people have been kind of
brainwashed into thinking that oh that
that's real estate investing it's a form
of real estate investing but you're
putting up all the capital the time the
energy the knowledge and taking on the
risk to do that real investing means
that you're acquiring and building a
portfolio of income producing assets
that are generating passive income so
that way you don't have to work every
month or every year you can live off of
the income from your assets and it
doesn't have to be real estate it could
be other stuff but I just happen to love
real estate because it is the most
powerful wealth creation tool and you
could do it the fastest so for the most
part if I had to pick one absolutely I'd
be a passive real estate investor you
help people achieve their own wealth
breakthroughs I guess through for your
Educational Services uh in part at least
so let's say I'm somebody who I want
this now I decid I'm going to get on a
path here um I want to walk you know I
walk into your environment you know your
services and I say okay here I am how do
I get started what what are the steps
that you take me through to turn me into
a real estate investor that can build
wealth so 99% of the time when someone
actually contacts us whether by phone or
on our website they they have two things
it's what I call their capacity MH
capacity comes down to two things cash
and credit MH so credit is the ability
to qualify for long-term financing
essentially a 30-year fixed rate
mortgage which is beautiful it's great
debt not good debt it's great debt so
the capacity to qualify uh the credit to
qualifying the capacity meaning the
capital you can invest with as little as
18 20,000 $25,000 because let's face it
most of the income producing real estate
that builds a great portfolio is in the
range of 100 to to $200,000 for a normal
three-bedroom two bath home in a good
quality neighborhood what I'll call a B+
neighborhood MH so that's all you really
need in terms of capacity so when those
people come to us they've already
somewhat self selected themselves and
educated themselves and a lot of times
it's because of our podcast or books
that they've been reading such as the
ones we just talked about and now
they're saying hey I'm ready I'm I'm
willing to move forward I just need
someone to hold my hand and I need the
team so the reason would come to us and
I I don't say this to be you know um you
know a pitch or um you know
self-promotion but the reality is is we
are have already vetted all the teams of
people that you would need in 20 to 25
different markets so let's talk about
what you know who needs to be on this
team so pretend for a minute you don't
exist but you know as far as you don't
have a team or something to plug in and
I'm trying to go out figure this out
learn how to do this so assuming you
didn't have that team now you're say
okay you checked you know what what what
kind of capital I have what kind of
credit do I have and I've got the
ability to get started from those two
things what's the next thing I do the
really the starting point is to build
your team but the starting point to that
is really to have a conversation or two
what I call a strategy session with
someone who's already an experienced
real estate investor and can hold your
hand and guide you along and for us we
call them investment counselors because
they're essentially counseling you so
what's the key like so let's say the you
know you didn't have a team when you got
started you know it was you basically
getting figure it out so was you so you
you found property you had certain
criteria around it I'm assuming so what
kind of criteria I'm looking for so okay
great question so now that builds out to
you know a whole other conversation so
when I first started in late 2003 early
2004 I was living in Orange County
California and I was investing 2 to
3,000 miles away from Florida all the
way up to Michigan I didn't have a team
I had to build my team so I had to not
only find and vet the people that were
going to be on my team but I had to
create the systems that would allow me
to invest from a long distance and do it
successfully and sure I've lost a lot of
money in the process I've tripped fell
got kicked in the gut and that's
actually important so let's go into the
mistake so the roles for the team are
what I guess you need a realtor to find
property for you right that you can
trust that knows what you're looking for
uh is a part of that team of Bankers A
lender somebody that you know uh is is
predisposed to understanding you and
being able to lend so let's address that
question first so here are the key
people on your team there there there's
going to be more you need an
Acquisitions person it may not be a
realtor it just depends on what your
strategy is but essentially someone
who's going to bring you the deals okay
it could be a new home builder could be
a turnkey real estate provider it could
be a real estate agent or broker um
where they're just pulling it off the
MLS maybe you're dealing with a
wholesaler because you're doing some of
the work it's an active approach that
becomes a passive investment MH so your
acquisitions person second you need
financing so you're going to need
lenders and mortgage brokers to be able
to get you the financing because you
could leverage your money 5 to one which
is fantastic you need Property
Management key person on your team
property management is critical in fact
I jokingly say you live and die by your
property manager uh so you really need
professional full service Property
Management in all the markets unless
you're managing it yourself what do you
allocate uh for a percentage of the
income to Property Management I always
budget 10% the reality is because of the
relationships we have it'll range from 7
to 10 it averages 8% okay uh but at the
end of the day I'm not going to nickel
and die on my property manager the cost
difference between 8 n and 10% is
nominal I just want to have great
management and I want my manager
focusing on me and my my inventory my
portfolio in other words my assets as
much as possible because at the end of
the day I want them least for as long as
possible the the expense in owning
property is not that 8 n 10% management
fee it's really the turnover the turns
are the costly expenses in owning
investment property now now it's a
built-in cost you expect it you budget
for it and you plan for it so it's not
like it's going to be a shock or or a
surprise but the longer you maintain and
keep a tenant without having that
turnover uh the more of that cash flow
or positive cash flow you retain so we
got three key members of the team you
know somebody help with acquisition
lender and Property Management
Professional Property Management I think
is the term used what other members do
you think are necessary well I'll add
two more to that list because these are
people that you're in communication with
on a regular basis be it monthly
quarterly semiannually or annually and
that is your asset protection attorney
and your tax adviser you'll always be
working with a tax adviser because your
your tax situation will change from year
to year and you always want to minimize
reduce and eliminate taxes and so a tax
adviser will be the KE person on your
team for that and that are they
Specialists pretty much in this area
they need to like specialize here or a
typical tax adviser would work I would
say that they need to be specialized
enough in the sense that they truly
understand investment real estate and
the tax laws surrounding it ideally if
they're Real Estate Investors themselves
you can probably be assured that they
understand that's actually really good
little do you invest to real estate good
you can work with me right exactly I
like that um and then that person is
going to be in communication with your
asset protection attorney from time to
time because all the entities that you
have as um as asset protection vehicles
have to fit the financial strategy you
that you have that's being set up by
your financial advisor so there is tax
impact or implications from each entity
that you set up and where you reside um
and and what states you invest in so
those two people are are going to be
communicating when we uh interview
interviewed Robert kiaki for a previous
series uh he talked about the great tax
advantage and others have too in real
estate investment so can you walk me
through that like what you know if I'm
somebody that says Hey I want to get
it's hard it's hard to uh accumulate
wealth when you're getting taxed to
death as soon as you start making more
money you get less of it and it's like
how do you start to accumulate any real
wealth but it seems that through real
estate investment there's ways to get
great tax advantage can you speak to
that a bit Yeah so not being a CPA or a
tax adviser I I I will give you kind of
the nuts and bolts essentially if you do
it right you can own real estate income
producing real estate and build a
portfolio and become not only wealthy
but Rich at the same time without paying
tax which means that it's not that
you're breaking rules or avoiding to pay
tax what you're doing is you're
deferring you're minimizing your tax
impact and you're deferring tax done the
right way you could defer it forever and
then ultimately when you pass your
portfolio down to your heirs there's a
reset in the cost basis of that U
portfolio where now the people who
inherit your your real estate portfolio
are starting at a new cost basis so they
don't pay any tax but the short answer
to your question to get to that is
number one you have passive income
coming from your properties when your
taxes are done right by your your Tax
Advisor the depreciation that you get
from the
properties can minimize or essentially
elate the tax impact from that passive
income that's the first there's a second
as well uh the second is the fact that
you build equity over time in your
portfolio which creates net worth
creates wealth um and then you take that
and you build more wealth which is
something we can talk about but if you
were to sell that property you would be
responsible for paying capital gains
taxes right but if you do something
through the magic of what's called a
1031 tax deferred exchange which is just
the tax code in the IRS book called 1031
it allows you to effectively sell
property and take the equity and roll it
into other real estate more real estate
which allows you to accelerate your
wealth creation because now you're
leveraging up and building a larger
portfolio quickly from the equity gains
from the previous properties and you
don't have to pay taxes on that or at
least not now and if you do it right
ever you basically just keep deferring
it so if if I were to do you know maybe
a high level walkth through if I'm
understanding correctly basically you've
got um you can offset your passive
income you know from a tax advantage
that there is as far as uh depreciating
the property and so when you pay 20%
down uh you know you only have 20%
capital in but you depreciate 100% of
whatever the value the cop the property
is over some period of time and then
when you do sell and you have the
windfall rather than paying tax on the
windfall when it happens you can
reinvest and then you can keep deferring
that tax as you keep doing that so I see
how as you're expanding and growing and
especially if you're using debt to
acquire the properties you're offsetting
income that's that's how they're not
paying taxes and they keep deferring it
down the road yeah just to drill that
down into both of those just a little
bit more for for the sake of clarity um
the the depreciation on residential real
estate like one to four unit properties
is 27 and A2 years why 27 and a half
years I have no idea I don't know where
that number came from but that's just
what the IRS some negotiation yeah right
so you take the improvements which is
everything but the dirt uh cuz the dirt
won't depreciate but you take everything
else the Sticks and Bricks that sit on
the dirt the IRS will allow you to take
one
27.5 as a fraction of that every year
without spending a dime so it's a
non-cash deduction which is amazing
which means you don't have to spend a
single penny to get that deduction that
depreciation right now again if it's
done right you'll never have to
recapture that later because you can
keep rolling your Equity into new
properties and there's you know
basically it's it's the government
saying we want you to keep investing in
real estate so that's that's why they
give you that incentive rather than you
know you can defer your tax if you'll
put money into real estate again so that
they they want to hold up the real
estate market through that tax incentive
yeah yeah yeah so it's it's really you
know so now I see well this is why maybe
real estate I don't know of any other
area to invest where you get that kind
of Advantage there really isn't I mean
have you ever known the government to be
good at creating affordable safe clean
affordable housing for people no that
never happens right they don't know how
and they're terrible at it but they know
that entrepreneurs and individual
investors like you and I can do it and
do it well so they incentivize us
through the tax code to do the things
that they can't do well so that's really
what the tax code is if you look at it
most of it is about deductions not about
taxation so let's talk about maybe then
you know maybe a little bit more the
spiritual side of this for you because
you obviously you had a desire to you
know be wealthy you you created you know
this real estate business that you have
uh toward that end and uh and that's
satisfying of itself but is there is
there a spiritual side of the saying you
know I like the idea that I go to work
every day and what we do translates into
clean affordable housing you know safe
affordable housing for people does that
ring into your experience at all the
spiritual side probably lies within my
overall mission so my personal mission
has become the company's Mission and
that is to help 1 million people create
wealth and passive income through real
estate so they can become financially
free MH so that's that's our company's
mission that was my personal mission
it's just become the company's Mission
it's the vehicle to help fulfill that so
the reality is is we're in a country
where the population is growing rapidly
in fact the population is growing faster
than the the number of housing US units
we create every year so that provides a
phenomenal opportunity for us because
people need a place to live whether
they're buying or renting they need to
come to somebody who's providing them
that service right your tenant is a
customer of yours you have to look at
your real estate business as a business
and treat it that way and operate it
that way so if I'm providing you safe
clean functional housing and you're
paying me a, or500 a month in rent and
you're happy living where you live and
I'm treating you well I'm happy you're
happy it's a win-win the city's happy
they get their property taxes the
community's happy because it's not a
vacant property you know it's just an
allaround win so if you can keep doing
that feel good about it so you're
providing a valuable
service that's the best way to invest
yeah so your activities now as said you
do training training other people how to
do it you're an active investor yourself
that you manage uh so are you still
mostly single family homes apartments
what what do you invest in yourself so
my favorite is single family it's the
most abundant um asset in real estate
it's uh uh it makes up about 70% of the
housing stock it's very liquid it's easy
to understand easy to get into fairly
easy to get out of because you have a
very large exit pool of of potential
buyers or investors so I love single
families duplexes and fourplexes that's
really the product type that we
specialize in and that's really most of
what me and my my my team and I hold um
but I've invested in apartments uh I
just closed on a 22 unit package a
couple months ago in Florida so whatever
can generate wealth create wealth and
and create passive income and is a
prudent play a prudent invest from day
one so you've got positive cash flow it
carries itself and it's in a market and
a neighborhood that will appreciate over
time uh that's a smart investment you
have to have all those elements I call
Cash Flow the glue that holds your deal
together so you have to have that cash
flow because Equity grows over time
appreciation happens over time it just
has to in an inflationary environment
like we have so if you can have the
longevity the sustainability to be in
the game and invest intelligently you
will become wealthy what are the hazards
what you know what are the potential
pitfalls for getting into the type of
real estate investing that you recommend
one of the biggest mistakes I see
investors make and I made this myself
early on um multiple
times is uh thinking that I'm going to
dip my toes in the water or I'm going to
start small um which means for a lot of
people that I'm going to purchase a 40
or $50,000 rental property which often
is in a cc maybe a d-class neighborhood
the problem with that is a couple fold
number one uh and you know I'm being
careful in what I say but the facts are
the facts if you look at the tenant
class or the demographic of the people
that live there they typically don't
have a high regard for the property that
they're living in you know they're more
transient uh they tend to create more
damage they have more problems
self-created or otherwise um that just
create headaches and hassles whether for
you and or your property manager number
two that $50,000 property probably was
$50,000 10 years ago and probably will
be $50,000 10 years from now so if your
goal is to create wealth create Equity
grow your Equity so you can leverage
that into more real estate and increase
your passive income that's not the place
to do it so don't start small in terms
of these inexpensive properties in
d-class neighborhoods now Everything's
Relative of course you know coming from
California or even in Salt Lake City
um you know a C-Class neighborhood may
not be $50,000 it might be $100,000 or
$150,000 whatever it may be but uh you
need to start the right way and continue
to build your portfolio the right way
which means that you are following your
investment criteria so you set your
investment goals you break that into an
investment criteria and you follow that
criteria because that is your Playbook
or your recipe for what you're going to
be investing in and it it'll tell you
where you're investing and what you're
investing in so that's the first mistake
is is starting small supposedly but
buying inexpensive properties don't do
that so you mentioned one key mistake
that you've made you know uh starting
out and investing in real estate uh what
are some other ones so one of the other
mistakes I made early on is I hired my
real estate agent who was my
Acquisitions person at the time to be my
property manager so
she supposedly knew how to manage
properties and she probably did a good
job and I wouldn't go as far as saying
she did a great job the problem was is
that she had to split time between
working with clients as a real estate
agent and being my property manager but
really where the uh you know the
proverbial crap hit the fan happened was
when she collected $6,000 of rents in
cash it was a market where a lot of
people paid with you know money orders
and and cash she took $6,000 of that and
never sent it to me she claims she had
sent it to me she claims she had dropped
it off at
UPS um but there was no tracking and so
I never never received that $6,000 for
that one month of collected rents and my
mistake was just using the wrong person
you know for the right job I needed a
professional property management company
wow okay yeah that that I'm sure early
on was a mistake that hurt not to get
you know six grand yeah because I had
mortgages to pay yeah wow interesting so
uh okay well that's a good one to learn
from what else a big one is choosing the
right neighborhoods again you know you
want to invest making the right
decisions right from the beginning and
investing in real estate should not be
based on price or what you can afford it
should be what do I want to get from my
investment you know am I after growth or
cash flow or combination of the two um
what type of tenant or tenant
demographic do I feel comfortable with
do I resonate with do I want and so for
me I you know we classify neighborhoods
as you know as's B's and C's and D's um
and more GR manily you know A+ a a minus
Etc so for me The Sweet Spot lies in
what I would refer to as a B+ and a
minus neighborhood it's kind of The Best
of Both Worlds I know I'm going to have
appreciation and appreciation uh
potential going forward um I know
there's an an exit strategy there
there's a retail market so if I ever
need to sell that property I can um but
at the same time I'm not going into
premium areas where the pride of
ownership is so high that there is no
cash flow because the properties are
just very expensive and the cash flow is
just not high enough to um you know meet
the operating expenses and The Debt
Service for that property so I I like
the range of B to a neighborhoods uh the
mistake I made early on is I was
investing heavily in C-Class
neighborhoods and they look great on
paper but the reality is is that when
you have tenant turnovers they're costly
they'll wipe out the entire cash flow
for that year and unfortunately there's
very little to no appreciation in many
of those markets those neighborhoods so
you really don't stand to gain anything
at the end of the year I didn't know
that at the at at the beginning you know
I was still a relatively Green outof
State or longdistance real estate
investor but Having learned what I
learned through experience which is the
best teacher I've become a very seasoned
and effective and efficient investor and
now I know exactly what to look for and
I can identify it within you know five
minutes is there Milestones where you're
kind of graduating in this world uh
saying okay I've got I've did my first
property you know in the style that
you're describing then I was able to add
a second maybe a third at what point am
I in a new category how many properties
do I have and let's I know that maybe
you know what kind of property you're
talking but let's say they're $100,000
or so single family homes at what point
am I going from kind of an initial
investor to a little bit more of a
matured place like what are the and at
what point do I have to hire more staff
and team you know what what's kind of
the milestones in this path so some
investors choose to build a portfolio
where they get to 5 10 15 20 single
family homes or duplexes and they have
enough equity where they cash out of
those not by just simply selling them
because then there's the taxation but
they 1031 into larger properties as they
go so they they move from single
families to duplexes and fourplexes and
ultimately they take the equity in those
fourplexes and they start getting into
small and then ultimately medium-sized
Apartments that's One Direction the
other direction or strategy if you will
is to continue building a portfolio of
these one to four unit Residential
Properties and there's nothing wrong
with that we have a client for example
uh his name is Lance and he uh started
off with zero properties bought the
first four very quickly within one year
through us and to this day has bought
over 35 single family homes and he's got
a passive income of over $10,000 a month
he's got a great portfolio and a lot of
equity he doesn't have any in you know
desire to move in into Apartments he
understands and loves the single family
uh unit of real estate and he's happy
there so there's there's no right or
wrong it's really just what you're
comfortable with from a Time perspective
I'd like to think that you should
probably budget 5 to 10 minutes per
month per property or per unit per door
really that's just accounting you're
just reviewing your statements each
month communicating with your property
managers which is usually by email if NE
if and when necessary and um just
managing and overseeing so you're the CE
o of your investment Empire if you will
you oversee your property managers who
are your Frontline management they're
managing your assets and they're they're
handling the accounting and everything
else can be automated income comes into
my checking account every month from the
properties in each LLC and then I have
autop payments set up for principal
interest taxes and insurance so I have
inflow I have outflow what's left over
is my net cash flow and it just sits
there in the checking account until I
redeploy it into more Properties or
other Investments do is each investment
a separate LLC or do you hold all your
single family homes in one LLC
apartments and how how do you what's
your entity structure so that question
is an uh asset protection based question
there is also a tax element to that so
I'll give you a 40,000 foot answer to it
okay the general rule of thumb and I am
not an attorney and I do not want to be
one uh the general rule of thumb is that
you will hold your property Assets in
llc's in the state that they reside so
if you have properties in Atlanta
Georgia you're going to create one or
more llc's in the state of Georgia and
you will title those over into a a
disregarded entity an LLC disregarded
simply meaning that it is not an
operating business that the taxes come
in and go out they flow through and you
just report it up to whatever the
holding company is the purpose for that
LLC is simply for asset protection now
then the question becomes how many
properties do I hold in that LLC the
better question to ask is how much
Equity do I want to hold in that LLC
because you can have five properties in
there with no equity then there's
nothing to go after if there's a lawsuit
there's nothing to sue for right I'm not
suggesting you do that uh but really it
comes down to a comfort level uh you
have to draw the line in the sand and
say okay I'm when I get to $100,000 in
equity I'm going to split out any
multiple properties that I have an an LC
into other llc's and just keep it
Diversified if you will that way um this
is a conversation between you and your
asset protection attorney uh what I
wouldn't do is put everything you own in
one LLC and think that's good or okay uh
it typically isn't and I don't think any
asset protection attorney would tell you
to do that I imagine though you can get
insurance you know to cover a lot of
this too and it may be an umbrella
policy to you know kind of be a buffer
between uh what your liability is and
and what the assets are great question
always have insurance that's not even an
option or a discussion point so you will
always have property insurance to cover
for the basics you know Hazard Insurance
you'll always put $1 to2 million of
liability insurance on your property
proper each property then in addition to
that you'll want gap insurance or
umbrella Insurance to back stop anything
that wouldn't be covered by that so
insurance is not an option you always
Ure everything you own and then Ure
yourself you Ure you know uh uh
everything through an umbrella policy is
just a back stop so that is in addition
to the entities for asset protection who
shouldn't do this so uh now you know I
mean everything you're laying out says
my gosh this seems like you know the
best type of investment to you know for
for wealth development etc for all the
reasons we discussed are there some
people that you'd say you know this is
not the right type of a an investment
for you you should be looking in other
directions I would like to think that
everyone should own real estate but the
reality is is a lot of people are just
not financially
responsible unfortunately in our school
system we don't have Financial education
very little to none and so people
graduate you know high school and get
into to college and they they know very
little about money and how it works and
if they knew you know what an asset is
and what it can do and how to create
passive income and know that there are
other options than just having a job
where you're exchanging time for money
where you can actually put money to work
and it doesn't even have to be yours it
could be OPM other people's money where
you're putting other people's money to
work for you which is what we do all the
time as Real Estate Investors all the
time we leverage our investment Capital
5 to one in fact I've done many deals
where I've put in zero I've leveraged
100% of it and still been cash flow
positive that's possible to do the point
is is that I'd like to believe that most
people if not everyone uh should own
real estate the reality is is a lot of
people don't understand Finance don't
understand money and and are not
financially responsible they have a
consumerism mentality and if you gave
them a million dollars a year from now
they would be broke because they would
blow it all so no it's it's not for
everybody you you need to again have the
ability and the willingness and the
knowledge to invest and you can gain
those things you can become those things
the knowledge is is out there in fact a
lot of it's free it's given away free
all the time so you mentioned these 10
rules you have can you share you you
said the first one's education educate
yourself yes so can you share some other
ones yes so a big one is to be Market
agnostic and and let me explain why this
is a big one being Market agnostic and
this is really where I started in 2004
when in N9 months I had purchased 84
doors 84 units so in a very short period
of time I had masked a pretty large
portfolio but none of it was in
California in fact I wouldn't touch
California with a 20- foot pole it's
just too expensive the numbers don't
make sense it's a high-risk uh Market
there a lot of downside in fact we're
depreciating in most markets in
California right now so it's not a place
I would want to be anyway but being
Market agnostic is understanding and
realizing that here in the United States
we have over 400 Metropolitan
statistical areas and every Market is
local in fact you could argue that every
Market is hyperlocal what's happening in
Detroit Michigan is certainly different
than what's happening in San Diego
California which is certainly different
than what's happening in Salt Lake City
Utah every Market has its own drivers
and Dynamics so what is happening in
terms of price price growth population
growth positive or negative um the
rental market etc etc differs
dramatically in some cases between
Market maret so if you want to be an
intelligent prudent real estate investor
you have to understand that you need to
put your Capital to work in the markets
where it's going to work the hardest for
you grow the fastest and generate the
highest rates of return cash on cash
return and Total return on investment
how do you do that you pick a market
that has immediate cash flow an
immediate rate of return and growth and
growth potential and at the core of that
is really just jobs and job growth right
so you have to be Market agnostic in
order to be able to to make those
Intelligent Decisions meaning you can't
be married to a market if unless you're
Market agnostic you're not going to be a
very successful real estate investor the
analogy I like to use is this I do tons
of research and I determine that
Coca-Cola is the greatest stock to buy
today MH however I don't live in Atlanta
Georgia where the corporate headquarters
of Coca-Cola is located therefore I
cannot buy Coca-Cola stock because I'm
not in the same Market how ridiculous is
that right
so when you separate yourself from the
markets and you choose markets based on
the fundamentals and the trends and
what's going on you will
become far more successful than you
would otherwise so that makes perfect
sense you know you want to go to where
the stars align basically for what your
investment is not where you are
geographically what other rules do you
have so Geographic diversification so I
I hate when stock Brokers and you know
financial advisors say you should
diversify because really they're saying
you know let's not diversify you know
we're just throwing darts at the wall
and just seeing you know what sticks the
reality is a lot of stocks will go up a
lot of stocks will go down or funds will
go up funds will go down and you can't
really predict with a high degree of
certainty you know what's going to
happen so how do you Safeguard against
you know the changes in the market uh
which is emotionally driven very
psychologically driven and you have very
little control over you diversify well
in real estate you can diversify but
intelligently and the way do that is you
diversify geographically we already
talked about markets being different and
what happens in one market is different
than what happens in another Market a
very simple example is the more recent
um Announcement by Amazon where they
were trying to find you know hq2 their
second headquarters well that was a big
deal because it's going to bring
thousands if not tens of thousands of
jobs plus a bunch of businesses that
will surround themselves around that
Amazon distribution center because they
want to be right there to just drop off
inventory quickly and cheaply to have
have wide distribution well that just
brings a lot of jobs therefore
population growth therefore demand for
housing and so now you have uh upward
pressure on prices and you have demand
in the rental market and rents will go
up as well knowing that you have to be
Market agnostic like we were talking
about but it allows you to to invest in
other markets because of things dynamics
that are going on so my rule of thumb
very quick and dirty is basically if
you're building a real estate portfolio
3 to five in 3 to five what does that
mean means pick a market that aligns
with your investment goals and your
criteria that could be Kansas City
Missouri it could be Atlanta Georgia it
could be Dallas Texas and you invest in
three to five properties in that one
market now you have a footprint in that
market you have a management company
managing your small portfolio of three
to five properties you can grow it
Beyond five if you want but have that
footprint in that one market when you
get to about five properties identify a
second Market that's G geographically
different and often that'll be in
another another state are they are they
almost always metrop you keep saying
metropolitan areas are you sometimes
going more rural or are you sticking
close to the metropolitan areas well
that's a good question um it's in the
the MSA the Metropolitan statistical
area so if you look at a place like
Dallas it's made up of many submarkets
which are actually independent cities
they're not Dallas proper so you include
those in yeah I'm talking in general
terms like the Dallas Metropolitan Area
I wouldn't say you're investing in
Dallas the city of Dallas or in mcken or
necessarily you know Arlington or
anywhere there it really depends again I
like I said before real estate is
hyperlocal so you have to not you start
off by looking this is actually one of
my other rules to take a top down
approach you start with the market and
work your way down to the submarket and
then ultimately to the neighborhoods and
then you're investing in properties that
are specific to that neighborhood that's
how you get into the hyperlocal aspect
of real estate so when I talk about
Dallas I'm really talking about regions
within the Dallas Metropolitan Area uh
which is you know another conversation
but I I would just want to be clear it's
not that I'm saying anywhere within the
city of Dallas or the metropolitan area
of Dallas right so yeah and I think you
answered my question because I'm saying
okay when you're saying you know pick
five or you know invest in five and move
to another area you're saying completely
outside of the Dallas Metropolitan Area
the fiber in Dallas okay that that's
what I was trying to get it okay right
so we're going to buy three to five
properties in the Dallas Metropolitan
Area
will identify specifically where you
know the data is out there to to figure
that out pretty easily so once we've
done that you could do that in the
course of let's say three months you
could do that in the course of three
years it doesn't matter you've got a
footprint in Dallas in the Dallas Metro
now we're going to pick another Market
if I've if I've identified Jacksonville
Florida as being the next growth or
hybrid Market that I want to invest in
because it aligns with my investment
goals and criteria we start building a 3
to five property portfolio there and
then we do that one more time in a third
Market and we can do four or five
different markets if we want but that
creates a great Foundation of having
about 15 properties spread across three
metropolitan areas and that's the place
to start you can continue to build it
from there depending on what your
strategy is you can just accelerate the
payments pay them off and have 15
properties kicking off one to $2,000 a
month you know in in income and live off
of that or you can take a fast trck and
accelerate your portfolio growth by
taking that Equity that's growing in
those properties and
refinancing uh or doing 1031 exchange
and redeploying that Equity into more
property to build a larger faster
portfolio so ultimately when you do get
into your cash flow strategy it'll be
much much larger than what it would be
just taking kind of the slower approach
which is you know three to five and
three to five great so those are I think
some pretty good rules uh any other ones
that come to mind so another rule of
thumb is really um you know my uh eighth
Rule and that is used Professional
Property Management it's kind of like a
no-brainer in a sense there's no reason
why you should be managing your own
properties I I think your time is more
valuable than let's say an 8 %
management fee that you'd be paying to a
management company so I would rather
spend my time with my family focusing on
the things I'm loving and passionate
about and looking for more investment
property than trying to you know manage
my properties which may not be timec
consuming but it's just not something I
want to do I I refer to Property
Management as a thankless job it's not
something I would ever want to do I
certainly would want to start it as a
business uh so let other people do it
and you know that's just my my rule that
was definitely uh over the years an
inhibition for me is uh you the idea of
being a landlord just was never
attractive to me but you're saying
there's professionals that can handle
this for a small piece of the of the
income right and and so they're
professionals they understand the tenant
landlord laws they know how to deal with
tenants properly screen qualify and
place them why should I be doing that
especially from you know 2,000 mil miles
away when I'm investing in other markets
when I can have someone do that easily
quickly professionally and and minimize
my downtime another rule is my 10th Rule
and and that's a key rule if you will
but it's just a benefit of investment
real estate and that's leverage the fact
that you can leverage your investment
Capital with real estate 5 to1 m is
incredibly powerful it's a powerful
wealth Creator so I can take $220,000
today and purchase a $100,000
three-bedroom two bath home in a market
like Indianapolis uh parts of Houston
Memphis markets within Alabama like
Montgomery Huntsville and do very well
with that property I'll have a very good
cash on cash return but I'm only putting
20% down and I'm borrowing the other 80%
but guess what I get 100% of the
benefits I get 100% of the amortization
on the loan uh 100% of the appreciation
100% of the tax benefits 100% of the
cash flow and I also benefit from the
fact that
my 30-year fixed rate mortgage is being
advertised not just by the payments that
come in every month that by the way my
tenant is paying not I but inflation is
eroding two to three or 4% of that loan
every year so I'm getting kind of this
Phantom or invisible rate of return each
and every year just from the forces of
inflation the bank is not benefiting
from it I am they're not readjusting for
inflation it's to my benefit so being a
debt holder um meaning that I'm
borrowing the bank's money to purchase
income producing assets for myself makes
me me a beneficiary in many many ways
yeah that's interesting because uh you
know just thinking about having $20,000
sitting in cash somewhere you know and
maybe getting some small insignificant
return as compared to saying you could
leverage up have all the advantages you
just described seems like a very unique
opportunity as far as trying to build
wealth with smaller resources yeah I'd
like to think that most people should
start with $100,000 and believe it or
not a lot of people have access to
$100,000 they don't even realize it and
this is true for the coastal markets the
expensive markets like California even
in Utah um New Jersey New York where
they have $100,000 or more sitting in
their property whether it's their
principal residence or maybe a second
home or investment property I call that
dead Equity dormant Equity idle Equity
the the fact is is the return on that
Equity is zero right but what if you
could take that Equity even if you're
borrowing against it let's say $100,000
at 6% interest interest only loan which
is only $500 a month in payments but you
can turn that $100,000 into four or five
income producing properties in the
midwest or you know in some of the other
markets that we're in now all of a
sudden you've not spent that $100,000
you've invested that $100,000 all you've
done is youve moved it from your Ira
self-directed Ira principal residence
other property wherever it may be and
you've turned that into four or five
rental properties that are now creating
cash flow for you and creating wealth
through gains in equity and in five
years you can take that new found equity
and rework that you can pull it out or
refinance and turn that into a larger
portfolio and increase your passive
income and accelerate your wealth
creation so anybody that can come up
with $100,000 immediately whether it's
savings income or otherwise and turn
that into a small portfolio of five
properties and every five years you
essentially refinance and rebuild and
and build up leverage up your portfolio
in 10 15 20 years you'll be amazed at
what you've created that that is how you
can get to Financial Freedom and I I
break Financial Freedom into four four
categories if I can touch upon that yeah
please so think of it as a pyramid the
the largest part of that pyramid is
essentially what I call Financial
frustration you know this this describes
a lot of you know the American
population where they just can't seem to
get ahead you know they're they're
always chasing their tail they just
can't get a break you know they're
always broke whatever the case is
they're they're financially frustrated
even people who have regular income from
you know a w tube job uh feels that way
but when you break out of that you you
get to a point where you have Financial
stability and this is often what happens
when people get married now they have
two incomes coming in and you know
there's it's more breathing room or you
know you get a promotion or whatever the
case is but when you're financially
stable you're making ends meet you're
you're not overly stressed you're you're
living paycheck to paycheck maybe you're
putting some stuff away but but your
income is typically coming in from
active income you're working for it when
you start investing with the mindset of
building passive
income what happens is you go from
Financial stability to financial
Independence you've achieved that when
you have predictable
and sustainable passive income coming in
and that's the key it's got to be
passive income because it needs to be
one to two times your living expenses if
you were to lose your job or quit your
job you can still maintain the same
lifestyle that you have because you've
got one to two times your monthly income
you're covering the nut as they say but
it's got to be predictable and
sustainable then that last layer that
small tip on that pyramid is what I
refer to as Financial Freedom at that
point you're you've achieved three times
or more ideally it would be 10 20 30
times you know whatever your monthly
living expenses are and that's just a
matter of what your financial goals are
you know you set those goals not I but
Financial Freedom is when you have true
time Freedom you have enough passive
income which is reliable and sustainable
coming in that you don't have to worry
about anything financially you've you've
achieved everything you wanted to
achieve financially or maybe not but
you've got everything that would be a
concern covered and now you can get on
to bigger better things things about
your mission your purpose whatever
fulfills you you know spiritually or or
otherwise and that's really a great
place to be because you can sleep in in
the morning you have no stress you know
you can give back to the community you
could do things go on a mission whatever
it may be well Marco we've covered a lot
of ground and explored what I think from
a wealth creation standpoint it's really
a magical world this whole world of of
real estate and the way that you
approach it so I really appre appreciate
you taking the time to share all your
experience with us it's been my pleasure
Patrick this has been a lot of fun to
see the next episode in the wealth
breakthrough series check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there the attack surface for hackers
is growing
explosively this is a crisis the
blockchain is a new architecture for the
internet